one of the latest documentaries actually
it's a fairly old documentary but one of
the one of the documentaries getting a
lot of attention right now is ukraine on
fire and there are a lot of people
saying that the documentary has been
removed by youtube that is not correct
it has been flagged by youtube but of
course this is making it uh pop up now
on social media generating a lot of buzz
people want to know what happened in
ukraine in 2014. there's a documentary
by oliver stone that basically lays out
a case for western manipulation of the
ukrainian government which is
particularly interesting and a narrative
that is particularly bad for the west so
when you hear that it was banned a lot
of people you know their ears perk up we
got a couple stories but uh truth be
told my friends it is my birthday so uh
smash that like button and i got to be
completely honest
allergies man
wow i look out my window and i see all
those little leaves allergic to women's
day
it's the day when all of the trees just
like yeah
and then it's just i wake up and it's
like my lungs feel like they're full of
pollen and i was thinking like maybe i'm
getting sick but i'm not sick i feel
like spry but it's just like oh man just
itchy eyes and like oh my lungs feel bad
congested and it's just so brutal so he
sees a picture of a cat in his eyes
i'm the man of a millionaire yeah they i
saw them like you know he he looked at
bucko downstairs and his eyes just
popped out and i was like i got here i
saw those i literally before i came here
i took my inhaler just in case i was in
new york uh above the trees i lived on
cypress hill someone knocked ian's
camera away oh my god i'll slide over
all right well that's yeah that was odd
let's just get through this introduction
real quick ladies and gentlemen welcome
to uh the latest episode of teamcast irl
we are live
for you in the
tri-state area just outside of
washington dc and joining us today to
discuss a plethora of topics from
culture and politics is the rapper with
the latest hit single brian stelter is a
sex machine ladies and gentlemen ryan
long yeah you know what it is i just
wanted to give a shout out to all my
fans you know what it do what it do we
out here in the tim cass studio i just
want to say
that it was a little bit rude of tim to
have his birthday on the same day as
international women's day i thought that
was a little bit selfish of you it was
yesterday
his birthday or women's day women's day
for me i celebrate it for a week okay
hold on today is the day biggie died
oh
crap interesting
you know what i say it's notorious
w-o-m-x-n
so that's my rapper i'm a little little
woman xn what's the point so what's the
proper pronunciation i think
and for me what i would like to see
happen for women's day is i think that
they should make them eligible for the
draft
yes no they've worked hard they deserve
it i would like to see ukrainian women
take up arms they've been forcing them
to flee and i don't think that's right i
got to stop you okay uh that is deeply
offensive this idea that women should
just be eligible for the draft women
should be in every combat role women can
do the same thing as men
and you know when we talk about how we
should have more female ceos we need
more women in combat positions in fact i
think every position could be filled by
a woman we need more female doas
doas is that it is
isn't that a term i think that's like i
don't think you refer to somebody as a
doa oh military polish chef i don't know
anybody that's the thing i don't know
this but i have
i have also in solidarity with uh
ukraine
one small uh decision that i've made is
i've uh given danny a one month uh
suspension from the boys cast because
he's from you from russia oh you're
russian well no my parents are actually
from ukraine get out but the russians
feed it i got it i got it on both sides
it's like the first one so i got on both
sides because wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on let's put your
last name let's let's no so it's polish
chalk which is a ukrainian
so this is basically my whole life
everybody thought i was polish
and then i was like i'm russian and then
when i was 20
excuse me i found out that my parents
were getting nervous talking about my
parents
we're actually from ukraine because it
was the soviet union and then look at
him trying to cover up he switched it
we're telling everyone i'm russian
before and then all of a sudden he goes
i never said that i don't know but my
they are russian wait wait so but let's
just uh
do you guys want to introduce yourselves
yeah just like normally ryan long uh
rapper
podcaster
the boys cast new special out on youtube
white immigrant go check it out
youtube.com ryan long comedy just came
out hot off the presses nice yeah and uh
danny paulschuck
uh comedian i also host the boys cast
with ryan i have a live call in show
tuesday night's called low value mail on
youtube
and uh yeah right on we got it ian
what's up everybody ian crosslands i'm
slid over to the right a little bit you
got my floating uh ufo because your
camera's been knocked yeah yeah i think
i did that by the way i think someone
threw an elbow i did it on purpose
trump slid him over to the right a
little bit
i usually blame trump
yeah he does all right i love you donald
yeah i just wanted the ufo to be the
star of the show unfortunately ian got
kicked out of the picture anyway we got
it fixed but yeah i'm also here pushing
buttons at the corner love these guys
i'm excited for tonight all right before
we get started how about uh do you want
to just you want to fix that camera
while i complain about stuff no no um
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member and help
support our work we uh we had a bunch of
journalists and because you are members
we are able to keep them all employed
we're expanding we're building a new
building we're gonna be doing a lot of
really really cool stuff so i just want
to say it is uh it is my birthday today
and i'm eternally grateful to everybody
who's made all this possible very much
so it is a dream come true to be able to
complain on the internet to go from
man like 10 years ago
to just walking around with my phone
six seven years ago i'm putting a little
gopro for it up on my monitor to here we
are we got all these cameras we've got
cameras up there we got these famous
comedians here making us laugh it's just
it's just it's kind of surreal and
everybody who watches everybody who
signs up at the website is making this
possible and it's incredible so i am
eternally grateful to to everybody and
we're going to keep doing our best we're
going to make sure we have we have
excellent standards i check the news
every day personally i send notes to
team we do updates and corrections all
the time because i want to make sure we
have really strong standards for our
news we're going to be expanding we've
got on the ground reporters and it's all
thanks to you we're gonna have a
members-only segment coming up around 11
11 or so p.m and i think that'll be the
real treat for everybody because i
imagine that ryan and danny are going to
get you know i imagine when we're like
off youtube you guys are just like
really awful people oh no we're
too and anyone who wants to subscribe
for more timkat's comment it's just
patreon.com the boyscasting he
appreciates it yeah
we we all appreciate it there's lots of
content over there well so uh his
birthday present yes let's let's let's
start by uh just you know bri touching
on the stuff with ukraine a little bit
and then i think we're just gonna we're
gonna chill we got a bunch of weird
stories there's this guy who like
punched a 77 year old man in the face
because he's had a racial slur my
stepdad and now he's going he's like
under house arrest so it's an
interesting you know it's an interesting
culture cultural issue with like race
and stuff i can't wait to find out whose
side i'm on yeah right now exactly and
then you have the the director
the director of black panther uh
he got they thought he was robbing a
bank because he like walked in with a
mask on and sunglasses and gave a note
to the teller but we'll talk about this
stuff just have a good time we're
chilling some people were saying like
tim take the death it's your birthday
and i'm like this will be my day off
hanging out with uh with ryan danny and
lydia's he's gonna party like it's his
birthday i'm gonna sit here and mostly
just like relax and you guys can talk
and you know entertain everybody you'll
just let the allergies take over your
body oh it's brutal man i took allergy
medicine and it worked for a little bit
just sit down put some headphones on
listen to the sweet sounds of lindsey
graham telling you why we need to fight
russia that's right we got chickens the
only way that i chill we got chicken
city up yeah we did what's chicken city
all the chickens oh it's so valuable
it's the live it's the live stream of
the chickens oh like we're we're i
thought you're referring to moscow no no
no we we have them and you can uh you
can watch the chickens you know you have
coyote chicken stuff we do but because
we have a dog yeah and he dumps all over
the lawn and my brother won't clean it
up it keeps the coyotes and the bears
away okay so win-win so that's no it's
like it's like a lose win lose win-win
it's like dude clean up you know well it
seems like it's yeah like if you live
you know places where you have chicken
coops unless you're like in the city or
something yeah it seems like we had
hawks at one point but we built like a
mesh yeah you gotta really gotta get
them really solid in there right well we
still have hawks but we still don't
think there's like a that was like a
hawk attack you have someone you should
get uh someone from us get a sniper's
nest that's just always watching them
the chickens chickens what happens
24 hour around the clock you get 100 and
then you sacrifice them and then you
start is that why you need a constant
flow coming in
sacrificing to the youtube gods we have
56 of them incubating right now yeah 56
plus two babies should have got
that would've been cool let's let's talk
about this ukraine stuff let's jump into
the story we got this from washington
examiner youtube flags oliver stone's
latest ukraine documentary now i don't
know when this came out there's a
trailer for it's 2016 documentary
ukraine on fire by oliver stone they put
this warning on it age restricting it
now there's a lot of tweets here we got
this one from rumble they say youtube
removed the documentary ukraine on fire
we believe the public should decide what
it sees not google execs we're proud to
announce the producers uploaded the film
to rumble enabling anyone who wishes to
view it well i don't think it's taken
down
but they are they've they're also
they've also flagged like trailers and
people have started uploading this
in mass to youtube so if you search for
it now you can see like a bunch of new
uploads of this documentary
and it basically talks about there's
like this weird dry sand effect yeah
there's like a leaked phone call of
victoria nuland talking about who the
like the president of ukraine's going to
be i think you were mentioning that
right yeah yeah
she was uh had had some pics on who she
wanted to install and then it happened
right is that what it was oh yeah
believe the crazy thing is you guys see
that story about like the bio labs and
all that stuff
yeah well we were talking about before
earlier uh before we but yeah like she
they were rubio was like grilling her
and then she's like she kind of was
sheepishly like um yeah we're worried
about the
the bio labs might fall in the hands of
the room
if you go to uh the us us embassy of
like the u.s embassy in ukraine's the
actual.gov website it says the us built
two bio labs level two
specifically for food safety and
consumer protection but then it makes
like it talks about how they're like
researching pathogens and stuff
so i certainly think the idea is a bit
of gain of function how many i don't
know about that that's that's the thing
right so if russia comes out and they're
like they're doing gain data function in
ukraine i'm like that's how the fact
checkers are able to dismiss this
because what we all we know is that the
website and the us government said like
oh there's pathogens here it could just
be like they're researching
like they're they're trying they claim
it's the biological threat reduction
program to make sure people don't get
sick or something
reducing botulism
well that's a toxin i mean right or is
it it's a fungus or something how many
um bio labs does ukraine have in america
uh sixty four four four uh four hundred
twenty
[Laughter]
yeah danny was just showing us some wild
stuff before of the
the old videos of uh oh yeah zelensky
doing the roman salut that's a nice
pretty crazy yeah so well mostly joking
about how he's like we sure have a lot
of nazis here and everybody's like yeah
yeah yeah
it's one of those but then i thought
even crazier is like oh you know obama's
government we're gonna have to we're
gonna join nato but obviously as their
puppet and everyone's like it's funny
because it's true this is the ukrainian
president before he was president yeah
back when he was just a comedian the
conspiracy theory is that he's a
comedian who played the the ukrainian
president on tv show
and so they asked him to actually do it
because they knew that he could act
right
or or he's like well i mean it's not
really a conspiracy theory that's kind
of what happened but his approval rating
was like super low before this i really
i was reading something like my oh
actually my mom was saying but it's like
less than 20 how many fine levels how
many people's approval rating right now
is skyrocketing because of war talk his
secret that's the secret ingredient i
know you're getting the job dude it's
legitimately imagine you have a
girlfriend and you guys hate each other
and she's like you're the worst i'm
going to break up and then someone comes
into the house and you have to fight
them off
and then exactly
and the movie always they you know what
you you're not so bad now i realize why
i loved you in the first place you know
i'll check you out on a
i was reading this thing
and it said that
you can use men can use fear to simulate
attraction so like what you're saying is
turn the lights off no no they they say
like if you want to go on a date bring
them to a rickety bridge oh wow yeah for
real crack your knuckles a lot of first
date no no yeah you and don't tell her i
think i tell the girl hey listen i have
a nice night plan for you and sort of
drive out to the middle of the forest
pretend the engine broke down yeah
there was an extra
playing some squeaky sound find a knife
stuff like that she can't be scared of
you is this blood on the hood crazy yes
are you scared no there was there was
actually an article that claimed that
that if like it's true if you bring them
to a high location like the observatory
of like the sears tower or something
observation deck or you like bring them
over to those bridges where the floors
glass it'll make their hearts beat
faster and faster you want to trigger a
flight response no for real that's a
that's what they claimed bring them out
into the middle of a lake on a canoe and
then sort of yeah so what's it gonna be
well that's it's always sunny the
implication that's the dinner what is
that the dentist is that the dentist
system
no that wasn't the dentist the
implication of the the yeah he was like
you bring him out on a boat to the
middle of the lake or the ocean and then
you know because the implication they're
like what implication you know like
you're on a boat no but that there's
like um i'll tell you this for that
stuff i mean that's why you pay a guy to
come you know show up and be like give
me all your money and then you yeah
karate chop them off yeah or you like
you know if you're dating a blind chick
you can just you can do the whole thing
yourself yeah you know you can be like
i'm generally dating a blind chick
but uh uh the crazy thing about this
idea is like imagine this like you're
you're making a joke about how some dude
might
bring a woman out to the middle of
nowhere on a rickety bridge because he's
trying to manipulate her but think about
a guy who's dumb enough to actually do
that and it works out and he has no idea
what's going on you know what i mean
yeah he doesn't put two and two together
like why that work he just goes yeah so
then it works out for him and then he
ends up marrying this woman and then
there's the dude who's like i planned
that and y'all hate me for it it's like
if so if you're conscious of what you're
doing to manipulate you're a really bad
person everything's gross well i mean
everything that's like a human rule that
you're saying the same as
um when you watch cuteness or any sort
of thing like that as soon as you know
like when you're watching a baby being
cute it's okay but then as soon as
someone's doing it on purpose where you
go i know it's cute when i kind of do
this and they always do it it's like ugh
it's gross let's test that someone gave
me a pacifier yeah oh nope not cute
that wouldn't be cute if you did on an
accident well anything anything's
anything conscious is far more
disgusting true yeah i was just looking
up oxytocin it looks like oxytocin is
not only the the love chemical but also
can make people feel extreme negative
feelings too this is from the huffington
post i don't know how much research has
been done into this
probably none maybe this is part of why
putting people in scary situations what
does the huffington post think about um
tim's date plan of bringing them into
the middle of the forest
no no the dennis system to get them
dripping
what is what is what was it
how about this one you bring him into
the house and then you say you have to
go to the bathroom and then you run out
to the car and come back in a scream
mask
and you sort of
you go wow and then the actual idea was
to bring him to a scary movie yeah you
know yeah it was like invite him in a
day and then bring him to movies and go
see a horror film well yeah or turn up
if you want to dial up yeah that would
be a good playing in the 70s yeah right
that's boring yeah now you got to do it
like michael jackson didn't thriller and
like be a werewolf like actually
threatened and scare them like augmented
reality glasses
no i'm kidding you can always offer a
pair of glasses when they come over or
hire a team of hackers to do cyber
warfare on your bank accounts while
you're there oh that's oh could you
imagine that if some guy like you hire a
team maybe this is a good skit or a bit
a guy hires like 10 people and he tries
convincing his date that he's you know
special agent yeah and it's like the
russians have come for him because he's
got information about the war or
something you have your keyboards and
she goes those aren't hooked up to
anyone you go shush their new stuff
all your boys like right when the check
comes all the guys come and they go yeah
we gotta go we gotta we gotta go you go
no you're like at least before you're
like you like fight your way out of this
restaurant
and then you're like quick get in the
car if you wanna live you'll come with
me and she like screams and punches you
in the ball in the trunk yeah you're
getting in the trunk
that's the tinder swindler too
tinder swindler wasn't that guy just
like if you're listening and you're
looking for dating tips
hey ryan pop him in the trunk
i said ryan you got him all day the
tinder swindler do you i don't know if
you heard but i i swindled the tinder
swindler did you who well he does cameos
and it's uh 300 bucks but it's like a
thousand bucks if you want it for
promotional purposes but then i weaseled
my not promotional purposes but you
actually hired me i got him he goes oh
congrats on you're special and uh
do not like well that's been my favorite
thing with the tinder swindler is that
he his whole thing was to his girlfriend
it's always goes my enemies are after me
right yeah so i've been loving saying
that to everyone like my chick or
whatever it's like baby oh you have to
get the food my enemies are after me you
don't understand i can't be home by 10
my enemies are after me so
you could be you could be definitely
saying that like oh hey the stream was
late but you know our enemies are after
us over here
this is the first one you actually yeah
we got yeah
but but like while the show's going and
we're like oh guys we're sorry we
charged you double for the the premium
content this week our enemies are
[ __ ] how many how many times do you
need to be swatted before they show up
you go just grab a seat let's interview
yeah we're gonna have food waiting for
me oh yeah i actually was like should we
just get like a thing of doughnuts yeah
and you know and it's like for sale some
people were like maybe donuts is just
too offensive throw them at the cops
that's like more like like beef jerky i
think yeah or or you know just like
coffee cake yeah something that's sealed
so they're not like what's in this
poison yeah homemade cheesecake there
you go what is this the first time i've
heard the tinder swindler this is a
really never heard of the
february 22nd documentary on netflix
what is it you must know this is the
brief run yeah he was like ripping women
off yeah you're in the know he really
isn't i was actually on tinder he leaves
the show and goes right back into the
bunker
what's that he's like a con artist and
he just conned all these women oh my
gosh he's just getting like free food
and stuff though right no no he this one
when we gave him like uh she took out
all these credit cards and gave him 250
000.
he's got a lot and the thing is the move
the movie had three women in it which
means there were 50 that didn't want to
come forward so how do how do you how do
you fall for this stuff well that's how
you get them you get them scared that
all their money's gone and then boom
you're in what's the best the main way
yeah she's scared
[Laughter]
instead of bringing them out to the
bridge you bring them out to a
metaphorical bridge where their money is
all disappearing right well he tricked
them into thinking he was a billionaire
that was the big thing is like these
girls the first date he'd be like you
know what meet me at the airport and
then go fly on a private jet to
switzerland for a night at a hotel but
that's still expensive yes because it
was a ponzi scheme that was being funded
by all the other women who were paying
for this one thing and then she would
now be paying for him to do this to
somebody else but were these women rich
or something no but he just noticed
he was sort of involved in the thing too
where he would get the girls for example
he would write them uh fake employment
letters for his fake company so then
they can now go get their lines of
credits extended he was pretty involved
in the procedure yeah he had it down to
pretty decent science and these women
didn't know what they were doing it
wasn't that it's like i mean you know
you got some cash like if people were
like hey can you let me a thousand bucks
obviously i'm good for it why would
anyone believe that you wouldn't be
right especially if they kind of have oh
if i ask someone for money no if they
asked you yeah if you asked that yeah
yeah like if you asked me for a decent
amount of money like my enemies are
after me i wouldn't think anything else
really can i have 400 bucks right yeah
you know i got it yeah you got yours
well that's the thing you just found out
that i have more money than you know my
wallet well oh yeah yeah i'm good not
anymore he doesn't want to pull it out i
know i know he's got love he doesn't
have the guts to pull it out
lucky uh no more tinder swindlers from
new york post dating app adds background
checks here we go here we go
not only did we get uh danny and ryan to
come out here and do the show we don't
pay them yeah i actually just got him to
give me 400 what he doesn't realize is
that i just put the terms at 50 interest
per
if you'd like to close up the loan if
not your companion i never signed it
never caught an honest john
troublemaker
okay so yeah you guys are gonna be like
deer hunter later tonight just
russian roulette yep what red red
headbands at the moment it's his
birthday you can have the money back if
you want if those dollars are really
made a cop give me 400 bucks for my
birthday are they yeah are they worth
less than a quarter a quarter of metal
if they're made of cotton is the cotton
less a dollar bill is it worth less than
a quarter because the quarter is made of
metal like real value oh the actual
melts yeah yeah there's no well hold on
i don't know though you can you can wipe
your ass with money that's true yeah
although are there nickels that are made
of people do you see how much no we're
in venezuela
so like in venezuela it's funny when
people say things like in weimar germany
they were shuffling money into like the
drains and stuff and i'm like that's
toilet paper man yeah like i'm you think
i'm kidding i'm not kidding yeah no
you're gonna you're gonna go buy toilet
paper legitimately my dad i was talking
to him the other day that he doesn't use
toilet paper in russia
something i said something about the
ruble and then he was like yeah the only
use for the ruble is if you need
wallpaper right now oh wow wallpaper or
what a toilet paper wallpaper looks like
just but i'm thinking like in venezuela
they throw the money in the trash i
guess you wouldn't want to take that
really filthy money and put it on your
on your whole you know what i mean
because just like you get sick or
something this is that a nickel is 75
copper and 25 percent nickel i mean
that's a little misleading to call it
well i think they used to be nickel but
then i think they did that but nickel i
don't know if you saw what happened this
week with all the war stuff and all the
nickel comes from russia or like a huge
amount and then it was like all these
like commodity companies basically are
i've gone like bankrupt because nickel
i think it went up a hundred percent of
the day two days in a row
wow i should have bought nickels yeah
and then the the exchange cancelled a
lot of the orders they straight up
canceled them they're like what was it
wasn't it is it but it's not really
nickel it was silver right
nickel is copper 75 i mean originally
like when they were when the nickels
were in circulation yeah originally like
the dot like i know like the dimes and
stuff i don't know and i don't know if
in america but probably but they were
literally so you can you could buy you
can buy bags of loose change that's
measured in silver weight not
denomination so if you go to these like
metal websites yeah yeah you get a bag
of you know pre-1960s coins whatever
it's all silver yeah they're all silver
the price of nickels doubled in the last
week yeah it went from 0.8 i don't know
how to measure this but it's doubled
that's how precious metals are all going
up because of the
because russia that's a big produces
but there's a lot of nickel producers
who are like i guess they had hedged
their production
and then this is like essentially
because this is such an unnatural like
movement in the price that it was like a
bunch of them got bankrupted like they
essentially just like right
i don't know the exact thing but so then
they had to there's companies like
bailing them out now because you can't
just like take this nickel production
offline geez
whoa what is it uh march second i mean
that must have been war was declared
when putin went in right nickels are
worth more than dimes no then then
they're then themselves i mean pennies
are worth more than a penny but it's
illegal to melt them well i think
pennies are zinc or something
yeah but like the inflation is so rapid
now i just googled it this could be
outdated but it says jefferson westward
journey nichols 2004 2005. 75 copper
their value is 6.7 cents yeah huh so
that means inflation was so high i just
gave you 400 bucks and you just gave me
back 300 bucks yeah same thing dude
looking at the cost of nickel over the
last 10 years it's sitting here at 0.5
0.5 for no it's like a straight line 10
years and then it goes yeah literally
straight line
well i was reading some articles today
they were telling you that inflation's
actually pretty good and it mostly only
hurts rich people yeah yeah i saw that
too it's exciting those are my favorite
takes yes i love those takes but it's
actually it's bad for only rich people
and you go yeah yeah yeah you know it's
funny because i would even say as
like
when people talk about the gas prices
like you know how stephen colbert was
kind of out there being like you know i
don't know if you talked about this but
stephen colbert's take was like you know
awesome yeah what do we care if it's
higher right but i would agree i don't
see
you know normal fluctuations like i
wouldn't you know make much changes
based on gas prices and i'm not but for
someone uh for anyone to say that like
inflation and that affects exclusively
rich people you go it takes a lot of
mental gymnastics to get there well you
know look i can i can absolutely respect
that regular people are impacted but to
colbert's defense you know people like
us
it's very difficult for us to track the
cost of gas because when we ask winston
to go fill up our beds we don't actually
see the gas station prices
and so he comes back and just it's taken
care of and then we have a financial guy
who takes care of as you drive viagra
winston what are those numbers on that
sign meaning well that's what i said oh
yeah can you get me a bag or a cup of
gas or whatever
blah blah blah something something yeah
how much is this one guess yeah i go
couple guys how much do you need a
couple grand or was it gonna cost and
then he's it's no but like winston walks
up and you're like what do you need to
fill up the car like two three thousand
he goes uh one hundred dollars only a
hundred you hand him a hundred dollar
bill and yeah you know you don't realize
that he goes it's eight a gallon or
whatever i go
under a gallon is that high is that low
100 is that low is it low and it goes
well
let's let's talk about this weird story
because just i don't know whatever oh
yeah lme forced to halt nickel trading
cancel deals after prices top 100
dollars yeah hoard your nickels because
they're 25 nickel
the london metal exchange
forced to halt nickel trading the lme's
shock move came as western sanctions
threatened supply metal exchange russia
produces the uh nickel i guess in the
1990s a rogue sumitomo trader tried to
corner the copper market and tin trading
was stopped for five years in the 80s
so uh right now
i with the price of nickel being as high
as they say the actual number here we go
uh 2 250
a ton of nickels do the math on the
nickels you have in your piggy bank
they're 25 nickel wow got a lot of money
yeah says they're 17 a pound nickel whoa
so divide 17 by four into a pound of
nickels
maybe you'll have more money i don't
know maybe not but the copper in a
nickel is already worth more yeah but
more importantly they need them for
electric they got batteries right right
right so a nickel's got to be worth 10
cents right now right might be but it's
illegal to do anything about that right
yeah why does why do you think cause
canada got rid of the penny when did
canada get rid of the penny five years
ago yeah it's still crazy to me that
there's pennies in america yeah it is
weird with the fact that nothing well i
know but there must be i don't know it
makes no sense
how much money pennies is there yeah but
you know here's the issue you could
probably find a way to scheme
money by using the um
using rounding up and rounding down and
i i i legit well that's what they do i
legitimately mean this so no no that's
so
it's office space you're referring you
don't know so yeah basically yeah yeah
like if you go to a store and you buy
something and it's like 124 you save the
four cents then you sell it for 125 you
get an extra dime on top right but no
rounds out it'll run up to 125 and 120
two would be 120 124 rounds to 125. yeah
oh okay
but i'll tell you this but that rounding
is done
like you know which way if it comes to
122 you you win sometimes you lose
sometimes yeah what i'm saying you could
plan it you could so you could do a deal
with a company where you're like i'm
going to buy at 122 and save two cents
yeah but you're not going to send you're
only going to save two cents per order
you have to buy each one individually
like what like let's say
see what yeah you go i'm gonna buy ten
thousand things it's like yeah and you
save two that'll be the best negotiation
yeah that's not how that works build an
automated system yeah and you can you
can office space it yeah literally
but
you but also people can tell like for
example if you if you add the products
together with the prices do the thing
and you go but my system uh rounds it
down when it should have rounded up it's
like well then by that logic yeah i
could also just change the price to you
know scam an extra buck from people
without lying that's true like at that
point you're just stealing from people
so so you're saying band a penny yeah i
think
but then what happens to all the pennies
everybody's got well i don't know ask
what canada did with them yeah i don't
know um yeah i think they have them all
though they have them all at penny
gumball machines yeah
i don't know the only real people who
would lose out is those penny flattening
machines yeah yeah whoever runs those
businesses would be
now no i i've seen some of those now
that you know for those aren't familiar
you put a penny and then 50 cents you
crank it yeah now you just put 50 cents
in and it drop a token comes down and
you crank it it smashes the token oh i
did some math you'd need 1 404 nickels
to get four dollars worth of nickels in
in nickel okay if you wanted to melt
down and get a 25 i don't know what that
means 1440 nickels to get about four
dollars and fifty cent worth of next
what's that five dollars but hold on do
the do the nickelodeon do the nickel and
the copper on your piece of paper and
then do it by like hundred nickels you
know what i mean like no 100 nickels
that's so that's you know uh
you've got seven seven 75 of that is
copper 25 of that is nickel
so how much does a nickel weigh
you know how much and
yeah you have 91 nickels in a pound
91 and that's that's a fourth of a pound
of nickel
so you would have 360 300 i didn't know
this was going to be on the test i know
yeah i wasn't ready for this i didn't i
didn't think we were going to talk about
metal prices
danny came in he was like let's talk
about the london metal exchange the
price of nicholas has gone up recently
and there's a lot on crazy effects of
this war it's true yeah crypto solves
this conversation ever happening again
yeah there's no pennies in crypto
there's just a fraction of a fraction of
a fraction of a fraction of a penny yeah
that's better i don't know but look at
it this way if if the small if a satoshi
the smallest um
the smallest form of a bitcoin or
fraction
was worth one cent one bitcoin would be
a million dollars yeah so
that's what i'm saying and then in the
future people are like we need to get
rid of these stupid satoshis
nobody uses them for anything but but
they're not but you would because it
would just be like that's 3 000
satoshi's you know yeah yeah just be on
a ledger and then everyone's gonna i
think bitcoin is the currency of the
future
i think uh the the world economic forum
type people they love it and uh i'll
tell you this too you see that they just
yeah we were just talking about it but
you know but i went to davos in i think
it was 2017 maybe it was 2017. and the
whole thing was crypto like the whole
event like obviously the work on the
form economic forum itself which is
security and like high profile we're
talking about a lot of things but the
peripheral events they do because people
what happens is when the powerful elites
meet roaches you know like right now
yeah are they are they meeting yeah in
this room no it was i think it's a yes
us
diabolical we're talking about getting
rid of the penny
this is how it happens behind closed
doors
when you have like a thousand
millionaires and billionaires all
meeting at this privileged event then
you get a whole bunch of people worth a
couple hundred k trying to push their
businesses who show up at the base of
the mountain like they're in the
mountains
and then they put on events but they're
they're connected their friends their
family they're just not as high up yeah
and so when i went there the whole thing
like almost every business was like
pitching crypto and this is the future
they were like government officials and
family members i was meeting like i was
meeting like presidential families and
they were like bitcoins the future i'm
telling you and i've been telling people
i'm like i think i think the world
economic forum davos elites the global
elites they want bitcoin to take over
now joe biden has just instructed you
know they're saying you have to
investigate a digital dollar or whatever
so there you go it's coming yeah i've
either uh it's there's a there's half
there's one where it's they wanted and
then there's the other version where you
know you realize you can't compete with
it and this is happening whether you
control it or not
right
yeah i think so some people have said
can't beat them join them situation
can't beat them join them and then take
it over but but if they're if they do a
digital dollar they tokenize it it's
going to have to be on what the ethereum
network or they have to make their own
version of ethereum i don't think they
can make their own blockchain yeah
the idea is to make their own blockchain
and i mean or essentially nationalize
the blockchain or have no blockchain
which is even scarier it's just another
ledger that they control in advance
wasn't that essentially just the bank at
this point right yeah so so something
interesting happened i i we had to buy a
vehicle for uh for the company to pull
the rvs we got it we got a ram truck
and i bought it through a bank
and uh
they don't let you come in and buy it
outright many of these places so you
have to finance and they said would you
finance it you can literally pay off the
bill tomorrow and there's no fees or
anything like that you just it's done
but we won't do it personally why
because they don't take the risk if i
say like here's a check for 50 grand
they're gonna be like and then what
happens if it bounces we don't want to
deal with that have the bank pay it and
then you pay the bank back have the bank
take the risk okay so this is what we do
right
and then like two days later when i get
the bill like i get the notification for
online i pay the whole thing off and
then two or three months later i get a
phone call from this bank and i ignore
it cause i'm like i got no business with
them another day goes by i get a phone
call another goes by and then finally i
get a voicemail and i check it and
they're threatening to repo the truck
which i own outright and paid for in
full and when you go through they they
lost the transfer they lost the
transaction so i called they were like
we don't have any transactions from you
like you owe us the full amount and i
was like i went to my bank and i did
everything i was like i went to your
website i filled out everything as you
expected me to fill that fill out my
bank debited the cash and so i called my
bank and they were like money's gone and
then i was like where did the money go
and they're like sir do you know how
banking works and i was just like
yes and they're like right on our end we
wrote in our ledger the money is gone
and this account now has the money which
means they now have to deal with it
because we've subtracted it from your
account so like the money's just gone
it's like it's gone and then i called
the other bank and they were like we
have no record and we have not updated
your account i'd be going postal right
now if this is made blink well i just
scammed me out of a thousand dollars and
i was i was ready to burn the place to
the ground i was so mad well so i
tweeted at him and then everything got
better it's funny how how this how the
hell yeah isn't it you have to these
days but that that is so messed up
that's what you tweet at them that the
what the bank they stole my money
i'm not going to i'm not going to say it
here like because you already did i
thought i didn't say the name of the
bank okay but it was it was it's a large
bank and uh
they said did you tell them like listen
by the way the tweets and the tweets
about the start this is your first
warning i was like
i'm
and then they were just like tweet ahead
sir tweet go ahead and tweet sir what
are you gonna do about it and then i
went to my million followers on twitter
i was like this bank is stupid and they
called me back like i am so sorry oh i
told blink fitness as about to tweet and
they said
he said they
fix it
they said we saw it we did we didn't
care about we didn't the tweet didn't
matter but we did see the pythons and
the photo yeah and we don't want to be
messing with those but here let me let
me let me clarify like in all for all in
all seriousness i did tell them on the
phone i'm like guys i went on your
website i sent you this money my bank
took it from me it's not here stealing
from it you lost it you figure it out
and they were like no we won't and then
i said then my only recourse is what to
sue you okay here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to tweet about it i'm going to
talk about it it's giving me my numbers
and they said fine by all means we i
think we did mention it briefly i
tweeted about it and then also i got
emails saying like oh we're so sorry
about this problem we're going to
rectify it for you and then what ended
up happening was
i i pulled up the information from my
bank and sent him like i don't want to
do this i'm like why am i sending you my
statement yeah i don't want to do a
bunch of work because it's not that it's
like i don't want to send strangers my
bank account information it's got more
than just that one transaction but you
know what we're doing business i've got
a bunch of other transactions and people
expect privacy so what am i gonna do i'm
gonna just screen grab the one bar
saying the money went through and
they're like yeah i'm like okay fine but
anyway i'll tell you this here's what
really bothers me about our modern
society is that yes my friends i can
tweet and these companies bend over
backwards forward hey you can yeah right
that's screwed up yeah i was flying on
american airlines once jordan peterson
was getting mad at microsoft the other
day yeah and then and it works i flew up
for him i flew on american airlines
there was a storm we didn't know what
was going on we landed in texas
everybody was delayed i tweeted what's
going on with this and i immediately get
a message like we're gonna take care of
you skip the counter go right to this
guy and they were like we got you booked
already and then i'm watching like you
know 500 people waiting in line all
angry their flights are delayed
but this is a problem because it's
creating this i i don't like the
classism the elitism
where if you if this is why you get
virtuous signaling you get the
influencer deal people know that if they
have followers they can bully people
with influence stakeholder capitalism
that's right and it's creepy it
shouldn't be that way
it is a little creepy where i go okay
i'm getting screwed over by this you
know car company or gym or whatever in
my case blink fitness uh did you resolve
it by tweeting that i'm currently
resolving it on the gym cast right now
well you've been talking about this for
a while
i haven't been i've resolved it but i
never got my money back
what happened
i'm currently i mean
my
see those swords in the background you
know
as much as i hate the empire or dislike
being it the fdic insurance is like if
your if your bank account screws you if
your bank screws are you can get it the
money back but once that's gone if
that's not there it's it's right it's
worse than that because that was what
everyone says with these things they go
yeah just get the money back but what
they do is they have your account on
pause for a year or two years instead of
canceling when you try to cancel then
they open it up two years later and just
start charging you then because
uh blink fitness is the name uh and
because of that
most people's credit cards have changed
a couple years or at least you know
whatever percentage if you change every
six years and 30 of people would every
two years would have a new credit card
so you can't call your bank because they
just have you owe us money and it didn't
go through the only and then they go
it's going to collections so you can't
call your bank because it didn't they
can't even disrupt why don't you send
them an invoice
send them an invoice for what
do do the same thing back
well i can't i can't send it to
collections yeah you can
i see what you're saying you literally
could but wouldn't collections go i go
the bank owes me six hundred
there was there was a dude i can't
remember i can't remember exactly it
seems like a lot of work this dude had a
thing happen where the bank
accidentally um filed a claim against
his house
when he had paid it off and so he sued
them back and won like 1200 bucks and
they refused to pay it
he showed up with the sheriff and they
went inside and started taking the bank
stuff that's so funny but love it
i mean look i'll i'll be honest it is
really hard to to use the systems the
way the corporation's like
possible it's not impossible and you
know what else is but it's hard and it
has to essentially be a passion project
because you're going to spend a week of
your life to save a few hundred bucks
most of the time depending on how you
have it it legitimately has to be your
hobby sort of yeah well you got super
screwed because of the whole wrong
credit card because normally i just said
to you i know just call yourself part of
their business model it's two years
later but the point remains it is true
the only way to get your uh
anything done is to you know how exert
influence because they so as soon as
that happens you go okay so you are able
to deal with i don't know why you why
didn't you go laura loomer style and
just go outside of blink headquarters
with his channel
you just said which boys just yesterday
yeah
i'm not leaving until i get my money
back yeah i'm at the dunkin donuts i
ain't leaving until you give me another
chocolate duster no that'd be funny if
you showed up at the blank fitness like
a sandwich board and you're like you're
protesting that'd be pretty funny give
me my money back well that's the thing
where it's always you know you all you
can do is go in and sort of yell at the
employees that have nothing to do with
the scam
no i'll say the blink fitness they're
not they're right on it
like social pressure is is the way or
one of the ways and that's what like
antifa's been doing and blm's been doing
to get things canceled but it is like
power power no truth but power if you
can get the mob to get behind you the
corporation will back they have
obviously a lot of these places yeah
there's a lot of places you know the
blogosphere as essentially to some
degree their influence is worth a lot
less than it used to be so they've
devalued all their tools you've not
gotten your money back from blank
fitness
no i i it's the case is closed i paid it
and it's over but they but you're saying
that and i basically said and they were
like blah blah blah sorry and i go well
no you stole 500 to me and i'm not happy
about it so they they
they stole 500 bucks from you yeah
something like that so like probably so
if if you know i don't know 100 twice by
the way this this is i don't even need
to get in the nitty-gritty but they did
the same scam to me twice so they paid
it off in case i mean there is a saying
and they call immoral to let a sucker
keep his money ryan so so if hundreds of
thousands of people uh
you know who maybe there's no podcast
you want to message me and do a class
actually reach out oh just sent an email
saying blink fitness you took this guy's
money you blink in your money's guns
i mean if you go look at the yelp
reviews of blink fitness every single
one of the reviews is what ryan is
saying yeah nobody's like great jim
that's all they scammed me out of my
money
give me my money back like fitness
where's my
i lost a pound the first day how'd that
happen they took my wallet so it was
that you signed up you quit but in the
contract it says we're gonna it's a
they're gonna start your account back up
in two years or no it's because of covid
because of covid i basically put it on
hold and then they go okay you have to
if you want to work out you have to come
wear a mask and you got to do a certain
time like okay just leave it on hold
they go we can't and i go okay just
cancel it and then they go fine so they
go oh and then it's three months later i
just start getting charges again and i
go oh they go i thought you canceled
they go no we didn't cancel it uh we
just put it on hold and now you always i
go just cancel it down they go well
unless you pay this 500 we can't cancel
oh wow and to cancel it you have to send
in a letter to their corporate office
you can't go into the location that you
signed because i was going to the same
blink fitness system you can't go in
there and say hey i'd like to cancel
they go okay uh here's an address
send a letter to this address requesting
cancellation if they want it to cancel
they basically you're like you need to
do you know we're gonna give you three
challenges seriously i want to cancel
this account they go you have to climb
this mountain in under four minutes
there's like a they're like just go
through that door in the back and you go
through it it's like this like lush
elven paradise and there's a bridge and
try to cross it and a troll comes out
exactly yeah it is you've got to cast
the ring into the fight
and your uh receipt for cancellation is
in one of these nine boxes
you must cast your membership cards into
the fires of mount doom yeah if you open
the wrong door it's you just bought four
more years like this is probably
triggering so many of your listeners who
have gone through this exact same thing
buried this in the back of their mind
and now this is coming back well this is
how gyms make money though yeah
you know gyms
they they they know everybody everybody
signs up guys
make money working his mechanics how why
gyms how come it's always just let's do
this i'm explaining on january 1st
everybody's like i'm going to show up
and i'm going to get fit and so these
gyms in the first week of january get
massive sign-ups
for the next couple years right because
they know no one's going to come back
and so they're just like they tell you
because i signed up for a gym
and it was in like february or something
like four or five years ago and i i
still pay them to this day yeah well
because there's like cancelling is
admitting defeat as well like you're
essentially saying i give up when you
cancel so so many people do that and
then they're like well i you know i
might go but what what they tell you
when you're signing up they say to you
like this is a two-year term they force
you to be a long-term hoedler of their
gym membership yeah but um i i think
like i don't mind having a specific gym
membership because you never know if you
need to use a shower that's a
that's definitely 100 like battered wife
syndrome
no it's fine that i pay 300 bucks a year
maybe one day i'll need a shower
because you could just go in and pay to
go to use the shop when you're traveling
around the country several years ago
when i'm on like one it was one and a
half flights like two flights every
every three weeks like i would fly
and you don't know exactly where you're
going to be i've popped into one of
these gyms and i've been like right on
you know well the trick is to pop in
without your membership and act like oh
what the i mean that's the hack very
confused all the van people all the
people who live in fans uh the the kind
of nomads that's their deal is you you
get a
gym membership yeah you sleep in walmart
parking lots yeah that's the future
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
yeah i had a friend did that he was like
a camper kind of guy he loved it
but then but then he needed to meet a
woman and he's like i gotta go get a
house yeah yeah but what if you get like
what if you get like a full-size house
but you know with wheels
so it's not a van it's literally a house
you can drive yeah mobile home they
believe they call those
yeah yeah but like a real camper home
that's my mom we were talking about the
homes where they're like you ever see
them relocating an actual house that's
cool yeah and they're like driving it
like 10 miles an hour yeah and there's a
porch and everything yeah like a whole
house you know we should do we should we
should build something that can like
fold out into a house
so it's like it can be driven on the
back of like a 16-wheeler like you know
like yeah like i believe you're excited
i'm sorry i'm driving a tent no i you
know like with walls and like power
outlets
well you ever see those houses where
they they 3d print it they're like a
tube comes out
yeah that's cool we're getting close to
the right materials the meta materials
that are super thin super lightweight
super strong structurally well well look
nickel something like nickel
we're gonna build this house with nickel
copper nickel bitcoin and russian bones
right well
you know once you make enough money you
do two things you replace all of the
electrical uh work in your house with
silver and graphene
because you know because why not spend
three million dollars on the electrical
system and then it's a good investment
yeah because then no one knows and when
the apocalypse happens you just punch
your wall and pull the silver out and
boom that's how you get you're out we're
out of here yes right
rip it out of your own wall that's right
let's bring this ridiculous conversation
back to the war and stuff like that well
what happened was yeah basically biden
you're against blinkfield came out and
he said contrary to what i want to say
before was uh i'd like to make the
announcement the united states
government is going to the moon
i was the exact thing he said
spreading fun is now going to be illegal
a crime punishable by death
joe biden came out and said the united
states will be canceling its blink blink
fitness membership cancelling the blink
fitness membership and we will be uh
tying american coin it's going to be
tethered one to one to doge is there has
anybody looked into the possibility that
this whole putin ukraine thing is just
because he had a gym membership in
ukraine yeah
he could just he knows i can't cancel he
goes you know what well i'm gonna go in
there and i'm gonna cancel it myself he
shows up and he goes to biden in a
meeting and he's like you know look
everything's great we're fine with the
sanctions we're going to work it out i
know we can negotiate shakespeare's hand
here's one quick thing i got this gym
it's it's an american company and
joe's just like you're familiar with
blink fitness but joe's like oh dude you
signed a contract man you got to pay and
putin's like dude i don't go there
anymore and biden's just like bro
you signed the contract
what if you need to shower next time
you're here it's good
and then such like and then all of a
sudden bombs are dropping yeah no but uh
in terms of the war stuff like you will
own nothing and you'll be happy they're
talking to us about eating bugs for the
longest time they're talking to us about
living in the pods then they're you know
they're telling everyone to stay home
and work remote and then as soon as the
covet thing like disappears
all of a sudden now it's war with you
war with russia and ukraine and it's
it's like the same prescription gas
prices are through the roof it's it's
like this the same issues are starting
to occur they just found
and
the same things are happening whether
it's like hey we have a new reason that
we can just print money and then
distribute it as we please
yeah they haven't they haven't quite
turned on that spigot yet but that's
probably yeah i mean they just announced
14 billion to ukraine or something like
that yeah that's great or whatever i'm
just saying they have you're just saying
they haven't no they're not like the
trail they're covered trillions like the
4 trillion or whatever i mean that press
is is still hot
this is the crazy thing this is why you
know i've been saying i'm trying to buy
as much as i can for the studio and the
company instead of waiting so we bought
like five desktops we need them and
they're just like they're cheapos
they're small like you you can type on
them you can't really do anything like
you can barely watch a movie on them a
couple hundred bucks you with a monitor
and i'm just like we need them for the
office we need them for you know writers
just buy them all now because i'm gonna
wait and it's gonna go up 50 bucks it's
going to go up 100 bucks i mean
especially anything that has any kind of
chip in it
oh yeah dude we're gonna lose taiwan in
two seconds i don't know about that i
thought for sure i'd given up but now
seeing all these sanctions on russia i
think that the ccp is more about profit
i don't think they're really gonna throw
all this
yeah they're not gonna shut off the west
like that i just think it's the raw
materials i don't i don't mean china's
gonna
uh stop providing chips i think it's
just gonna be like we're not gonna have
the materials you know i'm a big booty
judge fan so yeah so when he came out
and said you should buy electric car i
was like that's good points i bought
like seven of them just to make sure
because you know i i don't understand
why poor people don't just do that you
know they just just buy a couple
electric cars you have to worry about
gas prices ever again you have to think
about it bro yeah you've got to think
about it just buy an electric car and
you can just drive it the funny thing is
you know the quite you ask the question
of these people where does the
electricity come from
it's like fossil fuels
doesn't come from this well did you see
i don't know if you saw the alberta guy
from canada because they were basically
when when all this stuff happened they
were like okay we need to you know find
more oil we're going to meet with saudi
arabia or whatever and the alberta guy
was like yeah happy to meet you we could
sort this whole thing up pretty easy you
just have to open up our pipeline again
yeah that's pretty funny do you guys
ever go to the keystone usdclock.org
and just there's it's like a traffic one
in time you know what's not union so in
union square in new york i always
thought it was the debt clock but it
turns out it was actually a regular it
was actually
my d size yeah yeah
it goes down you know it goes down danny
thought it was the u.s debt it turns out
it was his mom's scale
but you know the number is going down is
it oh yeah but what of the debt so the
number in union square in new york no
it's a clock with this it's a date and
time but the back of the the second
number is the amount of time left
yes exactly so if you're looking at the
number you're seeing the digits on the
right
going down so if your d size your d is
getting smaller sorry right
now it sounds accurate
good news for my pants because
it's because it's like pretty easy
budget two clocks puts it at like a
billion feet actually is good news from
the band budget how you can breathe no i
just i i we keep hearing the good news
from my back
so here's what i did i bought a bunch of
emergency food and i didn't do it
because i think we're going to need to
eat it i didn't do it because i thought
the apocalypse was gonna happen i did it
because i thought it was gonna become
more expensive in a few months and i'm
like if this stuff lasts 30 years some
of it does and then i'm just like
why didn't you buy the 30 year old stuff
no it's just to see what it tastes like
buying 30 years of food like is there a
way that you can no no no no it's not
it's not 30 years it's food that lasts a
shelf life of 30 years no but that's
what i mean no i'm saying you buying
food where you're like you bought too
much food it's like yeah well if we have
to eat it in 2055 we'll eat it in 2015
well because look look look
we've got you know around 30 employees
what are you gonna eat on that in the
next 40 years yeah
uh within the next 30 years is there a
possibility that there's a storm is
there a flood is there a blizzard is
there a well sure but i'm thinking about
it more practically like sometimes it
rains in their floods and you know we
got the river right there you'll be the
only guy everyone's eating their bug
burgers and you're gonna have all your
30 years of supply he's gonna have his
space food that's a thing unfortunately
not it's it's a bucket that lasts 30
years it's a it's like a day's worth of
food i have a question
did they forget
so the expiration date it's free it's
like dried in a package yeah you can put
it in a bucket for 30 years
but it's like one day of food yeah yeah
i got it yeah yeah you said you said 30
years with a food or something no no i'm
like no we've got like two weeks worth
is is there well how much did you buy
enough for like two weeks worth of food
but my point is oh i thought you i don't
think i don't think in the next few
years i'm going to eat it i'm like i
just think the next few years is going
to double in price
well right now i guess it's food you're
worried
what's your important folio i got some
of the sp 500 a bunch of nutri grain
bars
the hard coffee the pie chart is actual
bunker pie why don't you go look at our
store room we've got maybe like a
thousand
that's gonna be you just like eating uh
opening up and divvying up the bunker
food with the sword
all right everyone
this this behind me is a wakazashi it's
not a sharpened blade but it is a
sharpened point because it's more like
decorative but it is real but it's more
for poking you could poke okay but uh
but for the most part it's meant to just
be like art it's like i think it's like
a it's like a laminated blade or
something i don't know maybe it's not
right but it's not supposed to rust away
yeah it looks and it was like wow that's
for sure it was it's it's out i was it
it was nice people were complaining with
them all you got a sword and axe
oh that's right yeah there you go but
people were complaining about my mall
sword because i went to the mall oh you
bought one from a mall yeah it's like
just cheap steel right cost 10 bucks and
everyone's making ex-girlfriend's name
engraved in it yeah got some anime on it
and i'm just like why are you guys
ragging on my mouse word i know it's a
mall sword fine so i bought an actual
wakazami from a company that makes them
and i was like just unsharpened because
you know we don't actually need to go
around but then i thought about it and i
was like i'm going to buy a bunch of
actual swords yeah so i bought swords um
you know here's what i'm thinking going
to get more expensive might buy it now
huh i mean the raw materials in them
definitely will be
yeah the steel and whatnot yeah man iron
and that's better if you have to use
them like someone who and and who knows
how to use this in the springtime those
weeds man they grow quick dude whacking
weeds with a sword in your underwear
yeah it's more important just let the
neighbors know who's boss also the
system you're out you can see the
muscles deep july just whacking your
weeds with a sword wearing long johns no
shirt that's right the sweat flies
sneezing i got a titanium sealed
you know uh katana and we're gonna go
out and we're gonna we're gonna do the
lawn we're gonna we're gonna you know
swipe the grass titanium
yeah that doesn't matter
yeah and you're you know you gotta you
wanna get the grass the right height
yeah no to be completely honest that'll
keep people from swatting you again too
when they see that image right
uh
this this like i bought some swords and
uh we the food stuff although i'm
serious because it's like
if we've we've eaten a ton of it already
and that's the thing it's like it's food
you just eat it it's mac and cheese it's
mac and cheese it's like craft well then
you're sort of dipping into your
investments though you should never get
higher you don't supply i'm digging 25
you're dipping into the bar
you're breaking one of the crack
comments i don't know if you bought you
actually no this is actually true i did
we should get a thousand times more than
we think we need because they're not
expensive no it was just in case no the
funny thing is
if it does you know go to like nuclear
war with putin or whatever where people
are going to watch this and they're
going to watch it laughing at us
like even
the
they have everything we need because on
the one end it's like okay let's buy
this compound and build this thing it's
like okay that's investment one
investment two is like a bucket of slop
hey this is good food
pancake mix
can you find out like do you know what
the price of uh a good example would be
around y2k because that was what 22
years ago i'm sure they were selling
these things i wonder how much they've
gone up since then and then it would be
interesting to eat one of those because
i'd be 22 years old how old are how old
are you guys i'm 38. you're right you're
36
so uh is it just me or
did everybody
on y2k turned the power off at their
house on new year's no we did not you
didn't we just played magic you guys
didn't do that uh i wasn't i'm like
magic
i was not a friend my friend's house
they turned the power off
i don't know i think everyone was like
it's 1207. oh you did that as a gag i
didn't do it someone did the party oh i
always think someone did that you're
right someone was doing that in every
house across yeah every every dad joke
playing magic i just wasn't i was sick
that night yeah oh i don't know stressed
out you know that's the funniest i
remember i had a girl in a car and a
bridge when it was happening right yeah
probably that's the way to get it
the world's about to end that's right
think about how insane the fake news was
like how insane the fake news was about
oh yeah the media was saying y2k so you
know what we did at my house we had a
bunch of computers and we went into the
bios and we like set the internal clock
for like a half an hour then we went
into windows we did the same thing see
what happened and we sat back and
literally nothing happened and i was
like this is dumb so nothing's gonna
happen yeah and we're like nothing's
gonna happen they're making it up i
think they thought that because of the
way computers were reading data it was
going to like cycle to all zeroes and
like the banks since they were like all
the corporations but they were they were
able to do that
they were making y2k compliant programs
you could buy yeah yeah and then i'm
like it just changed to zero zero and
nothing happens this article from
christmas that was one of the most
embarrassing
like
bro this don't say gay thing is
basically jesus mullet no for real like
they've made up a problem in their own
minds
and now they're complaining about a
problem they made up and republicans are
complaining about how the problem they
made up is actually a good thing and i'm
like what is going on so like i'm seeing
ben shapiro tweeted them and he's like
why are you trying to indoctrinate kids
this bill stops that i'm like no it
doesn't
right it's like the left made it up
complained about it and then the right
argued it was a good thing but none of
it is true
they they got baited into you know
defending it essentially yep yeah no
that was one of those it's the don't say
straight bill by the way that was the
one as as soon as i saw i was kind of
like whatever you guys are saying it's
not that i go what's that what's
actually going on here everyone seems to
be lying yeah yeah it's it's so we
called it i've called it the
anti-grooming bill as kind of a point
and i say that to to as a point to
counter the democrats calling it don't
say gay no i know but it is that is the
sorry well as i say the better point is
don't say straight
there's literally no difference between
straight and gay when the context is
identity or orientation
so if the bill restricts classroom
discussions from preschool to third
grade on orientation then you can't say
straight what about don't secretly talk
about sex with students bill can we
it doesn't stop that
it actually it that's the thing it
actually encourages this is the craziest
thing the bill encourages teachers to
secretly talk to children about these
things i thought that they was banning
them from not really talking to children
no you aren't correct yeah this sucked
to have kids what you're saying it's
like the catholic church being like any
sex talks got to be one-on-one the bill
restricts classroom discussions from
preschool to third grade on gender
identity or orientation that's not the
bulk of the bill like the actual bulk of
the bill is parents must be informed
about medical issues involving their
children that's it so it's like a kid
who stubs his toe tell the parents the
kid got hurt if you okay let's say that
you are
uh the person who would be
on the non-republican side super in
favor of
kids is there anyone arguing that sex
needs to be taught to jk yes yes like is
that hundred percent
uh uh so how old are you when you're you
know jk
like six five so they're saying five
year olds need to be like here's what
you know no no it's four year olds yeah
pre-school is four years old and third
grade goes up to eight years and where's
that where are they arguing that should
happen so the issue is that this is why
i think anyone legitimately like is
there so
you know not like fringe bloggers or is
this cnn runs the story about
kate mckinnon i think her name is on snl
oh yeah and she does a bit where she's
first pretending that it's like you
can't insult someone by calling them gay
and then she realizes
what it actually is but cnn shows the
bill would restrict discussions of
gender identity and orientation in
preschool through third grade over kate
mckinnon talking about it so i'm like
do we sit here
and just assume
that the people who go on cnn the people
who watch cnn aren't aware of what the
bill is and genuinely think it's
stopping kids from talking about
orientation or do we assume based on cnn
accurately reporting it they know and
they're trying to teach four-year-olds
about
sexual activities yeah yeah because it's
your i see what yours point is you go i
mean
if you're lying at least you're just up
to your old tricks but if you're not
lying worse yeah or whatever so my thing
is it's also just strange where you go i
get the i think that people just
they believe any sort of thought when
they go this is what our team thinks
this and you go really you wanna like
what grown adult really wants to take
someone else's kid and be like let me
tell you about sex when they're four
but i think
my friends my friends the bill doesn't
stop this
a teacher a janitor a school district
employee can welcome
janitors should be teaching you that i
mean i learned all about
that because the bill says school
district employee
they can walk up to a group of 10 kids
and say kids i'd like to talk to you
about why you're trans and the bill
doesn't stop that what the bill stops is
that if they're in the classroom for a
specific classroom discussion well does
it encourage that though it just it
doesn't have anything to do with that
you're saying they're allowed to have
one-on-ones but they can't be teaching
in a group setting they are on group
settings they're not allowed in
classrooms not allowed in classrooms
specifically means the bell rings it's 9
a.m the teacher walks in and says
everybody turn to page 17 and we're
going to learn about oral right they
can't do that they can after class walk
into the woods and show them the what
about all that but they can they so
let's say there's a group of kids and
they're talking about the stuff the
teacher can hear it and walk over and
say ask me anything you want and we'll
talk all about it they don't got to tell
the parents all of that is still
acceptable and fine as far as
republicans are concerned i don't know
because they're still in a classroom
setting even if it's after classroom
discussions
even if it's like after school if it's
in the comments it's essentially about
the curriculum is what the argument's
about right right so one-on-one is in
the clear there may be some questions
about with more than one person but
nothing is stopping a teacher from
having a let's just let's just go to
that point a teacher can walk up to a
student who's four years old by
themselves pull them out of the
classroom yeah you say you're not right
yeah
and
but there's there's one thing the bill
does they can't say don't tell your
parents they can't do that so they can
still have private discussions about
this stuff they can say literally
nothing but if they say don't tell your
parents now they're crossing the line
they're right the teacher says don't
tell your parents yeah and then what's
this what about it it should be how they
say don't tell your parents it could be
like hey they can't they can't better
not tell your parents well they can't
discourage or dissuade uh students from
talking to their parents about medical
issues
so this is the crazy thing about the
bill and we talked about it for like
three days now is that if a kid trips uh
slips on vomit and breaks his arm
the teacher might go up to him and be
like we're gonna get sued because that's
our fault and they go to the kid and
they say don't tell your parents how
that happened just say you you you were
playing outside yeah don't tell them
that i had a couple extra today in class
no for real and barfed because you lose
a little so i mean obviously drinking in
school will be illegal for the teacher
but let's say a kid trips on something
it's a school's fault and the school
just comes up to them and knows the
kid's not smart enough to address the
issue and says don't tell your parents
the kid goes home with a broken arm they
call the parents out he was playing
outside the kid doesn't tell his parents
because the teachers told him not to no
no now the insurance now this insurance
like we're not covering it and the
school's like it's not our fault and now
that this poor middle class family is
being put out so that the reason i bring
that up is that the democrats narrative
on the whole thing is just like they
literally made it up it has it has
nothing to do with this bill it is just
like that's why i'm calling the building
and you don't say straight in your mind
you kind of go yeah
who even came who even ever read this
and interpreted that was what was
happening yeah gay and straight's not a
medical thing so what is the truth
mental health what is the trans uh
component nothing identity and
orientation i suppose well wasn't it
that if you're
you know uh k through two and you are
taking hormones you're supposed to
notify the parents is that the idea not
in the bill uh the bill just says if the
teachers can't give medication to
students yeah if a student would be
prescribing any kind of medication the
parents must be informed
i'll tell you this i've been trying to
get to the bottom of this to be honest
because it did feel like i go what the
hell is actually happening here so let's
say your kids propaganda salad or coming
around let's let's say your kids at
school and he gets a stomach ache and so
they say we want to give the kid kids
some pepto make his stomach feel better
gotta tell the parents
democrats are opposed to that that's no
because the the reality here is they're
saying don't say gay as a psychological
attack conservatives have fallen for it
conservatives are playing into that
narrative because the reality of the
bill is they want to make sure parents
don't know what's happening to their
children period it's not about gay it's
not about straight it's not even about
any one specific thing it's about saying
don't let parents know what we're doing
in general because then we can now take
that principle and do some critical race
theory do teach them whatever we want so
they claim they're not teaching critical
races more about that
it's it's just
you know it wasn't until covet we
actually learned what they were doing to
kids because the zoom classrooms and the
teachers got freaked out and like we saw
these leaked calls where they're like
parents are finding out what i'm telling
their kids
that's what it's about the the teachers
can't teach children things you know
outside of curriculum
parents can sue the teachers if they go
outside curriculum teachers can't you
know uh take medical action against a
child without parental consent or or
advisement if a kid has a medical mental
or physical issue they have to inform
the parents and then one provision is
preschool through third grade you can't
have discussion classroom discussions on
uh orientation or identity it's there is
also very reasonable things it's not
right you know what else there is
something to be said about if you want
to
teach like essentially your world view
and propaganda then be a university
teacher because that's like that's
basically the job you get to do your
course and you can kind of teach the
whatever you want and which is very
world view and vary what you think if
you want to teach grade seven you know
maybe just teach the stuff guys
never ever play lemmings
back in i played on like a windows 95
yeah i i don't know who came up with the
idea npc i think it was sheamus yeah the
idea would be
i think i was talking about how i play
the game lemmings on my phone and the
idea is someone mentioned they're
programming a version of it where
instead of lemmings they're npcs like
little npc meme and we're gonna you know
when you when you want to like dig
through a wall he puts on like an antifa
mask and starts like vandalizing the
wall and i thought this russia stuff in
general was a very you know from back to
back with kovid just to show the extent
to which it's so easy
to get people hyped up on for whatever
you want them to be hyped up about and
it's like it's funny it's funny to point
out sometimes but you go it almost would
just be like man it's almost just better
to be a politician because you go it is
or whatever if you have a real agenda
it's very easy to get people jazzed up
for whatever you want them jazzed up
about yeah yeah yeah uh and nothing and
the hypocrisy doesn't matter i mean you
know we're talking about all this trans
stuff but like all the stuff that they
were mad at people about for four years
straight
ukraine could be doing it all of that
and it could be you know on video and we
all uh we don't care i mean there was
that you guys before the show you pulled
up zielinski and he was doing like roman
salutes nazi salutes and he was making
jokes about buying hitler's book and all
that stuff well he's making jokes about
how mineconf was sold out in the ukraine
which is because the azov and western
ukraine are like militant nazis they've
been around no but imagine that was you
know some you know politician running
for new york that's you know
yeah but also like
you know putin was like we're gonna
denot suffer and everybody's like okay
whatever like that's your pretext nobody
actually believes that and then we're
the ones
yeah well but everybody but then you see
it you're like oh there actually are
like quite a bit
yeah like the old nazis and then
remember in the ottawa thing the
protesters and they go oh look there's
like a confederate flag there's like a
nazi flag you're all nazis and then you
go okay so there's
a guy then are all these people in
ukraine nazis then yes all the people
you also they don't they don't care why
i know they don't care but no that yeah
that's reserved for podcasters the azov
were basically in western ukraine during
world war ii they were like insurgent
nazis that were fighting on the side of
the germans right yeah but left over
from when when ukraine was a german
protectorate after world war one so
there's definitely like nuance to all of
these points but the point my point is
that the nuance is granted
very differently in every situation it's
like and it's almost it's pretty
egregious to the point where it's
interesting i would even see with other
people like oh you can't they're not
going to get hyped up about something
completely opposite a day later are they
and they will let me let me pull the
story we got from timcast.com
poll finds republicans and independents
would stay and fight if america was
invaded democrats say they would flee i
know this guy and he was tweeting up a
storm during 2020 about how trump was
evil and trump was bad and do you know
what he did right after the election
nothing he moved to europe
and i'm just like this dude
votes for joe biden and then within a
couple months the ship is sinking gas
prices all these problems and he's gone
and he's gone and here i am sitting here
holding the bag and i just feel like
yo these people are evil
right it's the banality of people it's
not diabolical evil it is you know what
neutral evil i guess you'd call it it is
it is difference
indifference as they watch things
crumble around them they say i'm gonna
vote for biden because i want to signal
to everybody how virtuous i am but i'm
gone the moment he gets elected i'm
gonna go live somewhere else because we
know how bad it's going to get and there
they go they go off so it's funny they
say they would flee because the same
people were like when trump had gone
moving to canada
none of them none of them did none of
them did and the funniest part is we
were living in canada at the time you
know that's rich that you all think you
can just come here
like but it's this weird american
exceptionalism where you guys think you
can just go anywhere we can bill clinton
vietnam
but uh with trump things things were
good yeah you know so so when trump got
elected these celebrities were like well
you know my 401k is doing well my bank
account's doing well i'm getting more
work i'm okay when biden hits and
everything starts going bad they're like
i'm going to get out of here because
things are falling apart and it's their
fault yeah here we are i would not so
these europe these people say the
majority of democrats that they would
flee if the u.s got attacked and that's
a crazy thought you know that these
people are helping steer the ship iran
but they have no problem admitting they
would jump overboard the sign of any any
conflict or turmoil leave us holding
that bag yeah oh i just said that
clinton fled to canada during vietnam i
think that he just sought and received
deferments to avoid combat being sent to
the jungle good job bill i don't know if
he actually went to canada well that was
different at the time canada actually
did take
uh people who wanted to not go to
vietnam i think but if you tried to get
into canada during i'd be one worse than
gone i would you know be i'd have both
uniforms in my backpack and then whoever
was winning that particular battle yeah
there's no way i'd i would do everything
i could and not get sent to go to the
meat grinder in the jungle there's no i
don't think i'd be fighting any wars
well vietnam i get but let's like what
would happen right now uh you you find
patriots if america got invaded would
you be on the front line defending
america no front line of uh windsor
ontario yeah i'd be on the front lines
of a gender assignment surge
reassignment surgery missed out firing
my way out of the floor you're in
america now
all right you are suckling the bosom of
this country you will stand suckling the
what's the reverse of suckling the
person
funding your
social people
we're being held by the ankles and just
shaking out of your mind yeah well the
taxes are higher in canada new york city
are they irs no no no keeping your
cities
and we don't get free health care yeah i
assure you that i'm not uh well suckling
off
you just put some i said you do and
you're telling and you're and to answer
your question yeah if uncle sam came
knocking my door they're like listen you
gotta join the battalion i'll go yeah
yeah i'll meet you there
you need a jester you're saying you
don't get health care in new york that's
but you do get rat kings you know
i do know i tried to write in a rat so i
did this move remember rob ford yeah
yeah the mayor of toronto
i made this movie about rob ford i wrote
it
and i tried to write in a rat king into
the movie
tell me about this rat king thing what
is that it's uh basically it's a bunch
of rats and then their tails get all
matted with like mud and dirt and then
they all get stuck together and then
they essentially become it's like a hive
mind thing where they because you know
now their tails are all stuck together
so they have to move in unison because
otherwise they're all pulling
uh so it's yeah see they're all there
it's called the rat king and they do
they move together well they have to
otherwise how you get anywhere wow does
one of them take over is the brain i
don't know i think it's like a symbiotic
like they all
it's like a ouija board you know yeah
it's like exactly it's like a ouija
board it's like a corporation for rats
yeah yeah this crazy dude i don't know
is it is it real though because some
people have said that it's like an urban
legend oh i guess there you go it does
look man-made
rat king phenomena synthetic rat kings
tears yeah i don't i don't know there's
rats everywhere in new york that one the
medium one
left second top left that looks real why
on wikipedia does it say historically
this phenomenon is particularly
associated with germany why does it say
that in wikipedia it's in the first
paragraph on wikipedia really yeah maybe
okay and that's 4chan getting in there
yeah what the heck that's weird maybe
germany has rat kings i mean but you're
saying new york city
yeah maybe oh squirrels do the same
thing oh interesting squirrel king just
doesn't have a good one no yes yeah it
doesn't roll off yeah have you ever seen
a squirrel they do once they once you
put them in your rectum they get tangled
it's a family-friendly show
have you ever seen a squirrel
or as a medical procedure
what is it
so they're not real but i was in new
york i was in central park and i saw it
was a genetic it was like a chimeric
squirrel
something happened to it where it's tail
part of it didn't have fur and part of
it didn't have like poof it was out
partly albino like a mange so like no no
no it was like half albino squirrel and
so it looked half rat and half squirrel
but they they can't procreate so it's
not a real thing a square rat but people
think they are because they'll see these
mutant squirrels right with like less
hair on one side and they think it's
like a mutant you know like a hybrid huh
yeah it's just they're
ill and diseased right
no it could just be a genetic thing yeah
it's just like
mutation yeah yeah they're they are uh
aggressive in new york oh yeah rats
squirrels
and the homeless yeah
the squirrels i used to feed them and
they'd come up and then every once in a
while you get one that would just grab
the bag of nuts and run and and pigeons
you can hold out your hand and the
pigeons will jump on you you can walk up
to a pigeon in new york and hold that
food it'll jump into here and start
eating yeah they don't have any they're
not afraid
and then what you do is you grab it
and they can't get away and then you
take it home mike tyson
mike tyson's gonna be sad that you said
that yeah they used to they used to do
that you know right what's that the i
think was the there was it the passenger
pigeon
was it that was the extinct one yeah in
new york they would like go with a net
and just catch pigeon and eat them yep
could you imagine living that way like
going out in new york and putting up a
rat trap and being like we got some meat
tonight
i mean it's crazy right that's what they
do that's the north korean camps or
whatever you know they put them in the
labor camps that's a delicacy you should
be so lucky to catch him
pigeon people don't realize when we say
when you're eating all your bunker food
that's what me and ryan are going to be
eating in new york city
we're going to be literally being like
that's fine as a pigeon
i wish we bought some of those bunker
supplies
feasting on that sweet sweet
compacted granola yeah rice and beans
yeah just right just rice and beans
you got the trinidad so we're gonna
we're gonna be sitting there the bunker
mob
we got chili powder and paprika and
we're going to be sitting there and
we're going to be you know dancing and
like yeah you know eating rice and beans
and you guys are going to be munching on
rat and you're going to be like tim was
right the whole time we're going to be
your hair's going to be falling out from
the radiation speaking russian and
chinese and mix
russian ease
this tradition you can plant dry beans
from the grocery store i never
thoroughly thought that through but
that's awesome you could eat them or
plant them we just now you're just
rubbing it in yeah so now you have a
garden fence
we use an endless supply of beans
we got a lot of beans we can eat danny's
uh crypto portfolio yeah that's gonna be
very useful in the end of times it's
crazy to think uh
you know if you go to certain higher end
restaurants they are often out of things
because they're hard to come by and
we've we've uh
every time i go there and ask for a hot
dog they're always out of it well
there's a there's a steakhouse nearby
and it's like they they were out of
certain stake they're like oh i don't
have this meat whenever that meat it's
hard to get it's really expensive the
prices are going up you can't afford it
but we're so we're so luxurious in the
united states that we don't even think
twice about going into a local diner and
saying for breakfast i want like a
sirloin top sirloin with scrambled eggs
and they're like yup no problem and
there are countries where you're like
getting protein is unheard of yeah so
it's just so
like americans totally that's like a one
you get that for 10 bucks yeah and
that's why they keep saying you'll own
nothing and you'll be happy because
they're like time to eat some bugs dude
and for me well i mean for most people
they do own nothing so that won't change
very much but i mean
there's an idea of you know 15 years ago
people used to own houses you know
people don't really own houses anymore
but this is because we've been taken
over by oligarchs no for real you know
so i i talk about wealth inequality
every so often because i think it's a
big problem and there's you know it's a
very common trope on the right where
it's like
relatively dismissive of it's not an
issue it doesn't come up as often yeah
but when you have a small handful of
ultra wealthy elites what they do is
like almost every time they buy up as
much property as they can because
property is mandatory well that's
happening now yeah exactly so when i
visited ukraine we saw this the new rush
i was looking at lofts in ukraine in
like 2013 and the prices were comparable
to like a house in in america and i
asked my ukrainian friend how is that
possible and she was like it's a bunch
of billionaire oligarchs who own their
own everything
they have to park their money just all
over the world and so they trade amongst
each other but they but i was told but
the rent is only like 50 bucks a month
yeah and i'm like so it's a three they
take hits on them no not really it's
like
the the building should happen well they
just want to own the asset they don't
care about the uh
only other oligarchs can buy it so they
just talk amongst themselves like oh
yeah it's three and you want it okay
fine and it's and then foreign investors
that's the other thing too the oligarchs
know we'll put the price comparable to
the west because westerners who want to
get property in here we'll have to pay
it we own it all stars yeah that's
happening now with these companies
buying up i mean new york city
has tons of like some of the most
expensive properties are owned by
russian oligarchs wow
yeah there's a lot there's like i've
been seeing stuff where a bunch of these
places are going up for sale because you
know like roman abramovich he's like one
of the big ones and he's selling he owns
chelsea
he's been like the big owner and he's
like i have to sell it he's selling
chelsea because about this whole war wow
he's just like i have to get rid of it i
can't keep anything who can buy it oh
someone will buy it oh blackrock big
farm blackrock will take out a 100
billion dollar loan and then buy it oh
no
there'll be a lineup to buy that
there's no shortage of american
billionaires like
i don't get it how a company can take
out a billion billion dollar loan of
funny money and then just own now the
property's theirs because the funny
money said so like i don't believe the
funny money what do you mean like they
take out federal reserve loans which is
just basically fiat fake money it's
faith-based money and then they buy they
can take part assets they they use
federal reserve i don't think they take
it directly from the they take it from a
bank that took it from the fed
yeah they take it they don't take it at
zero percent i don't know no background
immediately this is how banking works
it's crazy when i swipe my credit card
the money just blinks into existence and
then i got nuts and these big companies
are so much assets to take loans out on
that they can take huge loans out and
then buy the assets and then sell them
back next year for double the price i
mean i mean all of this is just based on
the fact that you know the us
you can only do this in america yeah
it's funny money it's the federal fiat
currency so how and they know it yeah
well it's i mean like look you can take
uh you guys had your cash out earlier
like you can take that cash and go spend
that in any city in the world pretty
much other than the ones like north
korea where it's illegal or whatever you
can't do that with any other currency
right right like you go anywhere on this
planet and say here's a five dollar
american bill they go yeah that's as
good as anything
you're saying i can't go
you know
pay my top in london with an ethiopian
frank go try and pay with a 20 canadian
bill and just the look they're going to
give you
so here's what happens because i've been
in american money like i've traveled to
maybe like 35 to 40 countries and i've
asked this a lot and the response i
usually get like when i go to morocco
and i'm like will you take us dollars
he'll go
okay i guess because they gotta go
exchange it but they're like meh fine
you know i'll take it you go you do the
opposite you get like you know a
boulevard fuerte from venezuela in your
garbage bag and you bring to a dunkin
donuts and you slam 300 pounds of cash
to buy one donut and they're like sir
get out of here what are you doing we're
calling the cops they won't it's just
toilet paper to them depends on where
yeah
yeah you're not gonna bro when i came
back from venezuela we had we had big
garbage bags of cash and so did you
really bring them we didn't bring the
full garbage bags but we had massive
stacks take him the strip club no no we
just i i turned the cash in it was go go
usher style yo check usher bucks no you
bring the gun with the other gun with
the venezuela they give us petty cash
when you're working for vice to spend on
day to
me sure so we arrive in venezuela i'm
like how do we do it they're like you
can't it's illegal you can't do the
official exchange rate was like one
dollar with seven but they were like
that's insane because it's actually like
70. so a a guy smuggled in 70 you need
70 bills per dollar yeah something like
that so we had
garbage bags
filled with money and we'd have to pull
out huge stacks and literally pay at a
restaurant like
nuts like yeah it's crazy in that
hyperinflationary environment too
because those people there's no such
thing as savings it's like you have to
spend the money instantly it's just
happening the moment you get it that's
why you gotta have it on swords yeah
yeah well but honestly but the moment
because tomorrow that loaf of bread is
like have you five stacks of money
instead of four stacks have you guys
been watching sword futures
yeah
through the roof
i bought like four or five swords do you
see actually venezuela that binds now
trying to fix the oil stuff by buying
oil from venezuela desperation man yikes
and you know i'm just imagining like
maduro is like sitting in his office and
he's got like his belly hanging out he's
eating empanadas and like the phone
rings and it's biden and he's like shh
he's like it's joe biden they're like oh
like everyone's sitting around he picks
the phone up and he's like yes and joe's
like
come on man we really need some more man
we're hurting here and then and then
he's like let's negotiate call me the
tin man because i need to be oiled pal
they're all cheering and celebrating we
finally won we held out long enough yeah
oil
saudi
hello it's this white house on my phone
that says why spoil me
no just kidding man it's your old friend
joe
no he's sitting in a wheelchair man
with a blanket on his lap or oil me
and they're like what oh
and they're like oh it's joe it's joe
you know the oil man it's your old pal
you're the oil man i love when they
announced that they're gonna be like
they've done this a couple times we're
releasing strategic reserves and it's
like we're gonna be releasing you know
10 million barrels and it's like dude
that's a day yeah he said 60 million
barrels three days worth of oil yeah do
you think he's just next uh
but i didn't do nothing
what do you think gas is gonna hit
eleven eleven fifty eleven fifty a
gallon i think it'll be hit 1.50 before
people go insane you know what i started
seeing i just i just went out i bought a
couple teslas just to make sure yeah you
know what we'll keep someone in the
crowd
i'm kidding you don't have a tesla i do
have a tesla yeah okay but i was
thinking about buying a couple teslas
that's funny
you think i bought some tesla's
one no do you have a tesla yeah yeah
i do have one
i'm allowed to have one ryan yeah yeah
yeah yeah so no but it is true that's
the i don't know all this stuff is fine
this is why i bought the tesla no joke
so i bought it i think how long was it a
year a year and a half ago yeah no it
was one year ago i think one year ago
could you get elon on tim specific i'd
love to but i specifically was telling
people like i think i'm going to go buy
a tesla right now specifically because i
think gas is going to go nuts yeah and i
was talking about it all last year for a
variety of reasons now here we are
they're saying gas is higher than it's
ever been it's like seven dollars in la
county and now in the average is like
450 i think and they're saying it's
going to get worse because all of this
happening with gas happened before the
banning of russian oil imports joe biden
is so desperate he's asking venezuela
for help yeah that's how it's his
perfect story what are you doing buying
a bunch of gas and just having it all
stored here someone someone did that in
chicago
they took a bunch of 50 gallon drums and
they filled it with gasoline and put in
their basement because this was back
when gas accidentally lit a smoke and
then the house exploded yeah you know
what the phone oh yeah
let me pull it up you know so remember
when when oil went negative two years
ago you know what's so crazy is that in
the last two years oil has gone from
negative forty dollars a barrel to up to
i think what we're at 150 is what would
we hit 140 or something so it was right
when covert hit and then oil futures
like the april contract or something
literally because demand just
disappeared like there was like yeah
nobody's flying nobody's driving there's
no demand and so you could straight up
they would pay you
like if you bought an oil contract which
means you actually have to take delivery
of a barrel of oil like when you buy an
oil futures contract like you're like
yeah when this expires you have to go
pick up from cushing oklahoma a barrel
of oil and so normally like you know
it's 140 right now you pay 140 and then
you go pick it up they were like come
pick these up we'll pay you forty
dollars
what to take away but so then all these
people on reddit were like how are we
gonna we could probably make like a
fortune on this you know we just have to
store it but you're like you can't store
crude oil in your garage
it's like the smells that come off of it
and like you know
yeah but you need like real facilities
and there was all these people like
scheming yeah if it was so easy they
would be doing it well yeah first off
you've got to go get a truck go to
coaching oklahoma like show up there
load up and then store it until the
and i'm sure somebody who had everything
set up did do that that's why i should
have got tim for his birthday just like
a bucket of oil yeah i'm trying to find
the story i can't find it it happened
too long ago i guess but
there was some oil trade somebody was
trading oil contracts and then his like
account he had like you know ten
thousand dollars an account and then he
was he bought these uh he bought oil at
one cent a barrel because he goes it's
one cent a barrel he's like he didn't
realize that it could go negative he
just goes it's one cent can't go below
one cent right and then he like logs
into his like interactive brokers
account and he's like down a million
dollars
oh wow and they actually that's some
[ __ ] i would do you know what though but
they forgave everybody in that scenario
because they were like you know we never
told anybody that you could go negative
like there's no negative in a brokerage
account you go to zero yeah right yeah
yeah yeah yeah well you just got a wild
margin call kind of thing you literally
interactive brokers call them they go to
a million dollars and he's like what i
don't i don't have a million dollars and
how did you let my account go negative a
million and they go well yeah that's
minus forty dollars a barrel i'm looking
at no that's not crude oil cost for oil
looks like it's like 120 right yeah so
it's 120 it was minus 40. 108 right they
were paying you to take if you you if
you would show up and take away a barrel
oil they would hand you 40. because it
was going bad basically you guys see
that video they just had to you know
they were going bad you guys it goes bad
evaporating
no no they were because trump bought not
at minus but around then he bought a
bunch and i was listening on the the
milk thing and he was saying he's got a
big heat he filled up the the strategic
reserves and he says they keep it in
louisiana and these like mines under the
ground do you guys see that video of the
guy pouring gas into his pickup truck
into the bed he lined the pickup bed
with like talk with a tarp and he was
just pouring it in good old white trash
people were like dude don't do that and
he was like shut up then he gets in the
car and drives and it just like splashes
back and forth flies out i mean you've
seen when someone does that with like a
kiddie pool right
this one i can pull up this one i can
pull up for sure check this out
that's like chemical weapon things oh my
god that's gross that's toxic
wow that's a stupid humans
is that a tarp yeah he's actually
filling he's filling the bed of his
truck of course he's got a ponytail i
was just gonna say he looked at that he
explains everything
oh that's nice
jazz is leaking out of the back seat
yeah look at that
no it's dripping out what is this this
is a human being that guy's a human you
can do that this guy's not how do you
guys understand now do you guys
understand bill gates you're gonna say
something i do i understand how people
why the romans called people plebeians
like there was the elite class and then
everyone else they called plebeians
because they were like wait till he
dropped i think so this guy's got a
cable access conspiracy podcast that
only his aunt listens to
what's going on it is terrifying i think
there are people out there like this
hello this is not safe
you're gonna you're gonna cause a big
accident
what's he gonna do with all that gas
why are you doing that
you know that they they it's not safe
and they're gonna call they're gonna
call the the
much cops i can
dude it's not that serious this guy
rules
if somebody throws a
match in here it's gonna blow
well i don't think a lit match can go
off in liquid gas
it's the fumes though
look at this
how are they like people need to mind
their own business this guy's rocking
yeah they're the carrots watch this you
guys ready for this watch it move watch
it move he's going to drive look at that
oh my gosh
their brakes in front of you where is he
going with him they're following him now
oh you're happy he's going half course
well now they've got a high speed
pursuit i know right they're so sweet
oh
tragedy so that guy's wife told him that
he can't take the gas and he's proven
her wrong right now this this is for
those that are just listening it's a
pickup truck truck full of gas and he
turns left and it all just flies out
over the right side
these are human beings man dude and so
so you know what what luke needs to
understand look at cascade we're
changing he needs to understand he needs
to watch that and then go and read about
what bill gates's plans are whatever he
thinks there because then you understand
klaus schwab you understand these
powerful elites don't you sympathize
with them now after watching that yeah
as a powerful elite i get it
yeah i get it
the eaters is that what they call those
people eaters people i don't know if
they consume stupidly and do dangerous
stuff i don't know if they actually call
them that taker usually they call takers
they don't give they take
i'd like to see klaus schwab do the uh
like the circuit of all the late night
shows just to be like hey guys i'm
totally misunderstood you know go on
colbert oh that'd be great his doom like
his crazy futuristic leather
and he's like i don't want people to die
i just want to take away their fuel so
they stop and then there's this book
called ishmael alex jones came in and
was talking he was like uh i'm a gorilla
murderer you know and he's talking about
like ishmael ishmael's a psychic gorilla
that's talking to the student tom in the
book there's givers and there's takers
and humanity's divided amongst them i
think that we're looking at like 99.98
takers in society right now just
receiving electricity receiving food
not really providing for the future yeah
or what was that guys talking about oh
that guy must have just set a record for
at the pump like that was probably not
although you know with the price of gas
right now we're the idiots even if you
lost half of that that guy's still ahead
this guy's guys honestly listening right
now being like yo you know how much like
i'm up i have this all sitting here he
sold it he drove he drove back to the
gas station every day he's like i was
doing that every day last year he drives
it from one gas station to another puts
the pump in and it sucks it back up into
their pump and it reverses the counter
and he's like well maybe he's he's about
to open his own like kind of artisanal
gas station oh he's starting at some gas
station
i've been stocking up america
the patriots guest
yeah
we had this this bit we wanted to do as
a joke about you know bill gates being
mildly inconvenienced and so that's like
you know all of the crazy conspiracy
ideas people have about him
it's just like he's on gear right
he's super ripped yeah i hear joe rogan
talking about he's geared up that he's
like joe was saying how ripped bill
gates is and how healthy he was and how
he should be giving everybody medical
advice because he's a very healthy
individual mm-hmm i'm kidding
he looks like he's the opposite actually
yeah it was the opposite actually it's
only a uh you know he's only eaten like
uh sugary cereal with no milk for all
three meals a day like he just has like
a handful of count chocolates
yeah yeah that's what he's been rocking
there's a lot there's a
yeah he made a waterless toilet did you
see that one
well what do you do for african women
what they do in a lot of these
environmentalist organizations is that
the toilet is actually the top of the
seat like the seat is a foot pad
and when you sit the toilet has two
levels it has the seat up top you sit on
the top put the upper decker and well no
you urinate at the top
and then
you'd go number two one step down flush
your number one with flush your number
you use it your number two oh that's
kind of actually kind of smart sure
that's you gotta be it's well for girls
it's probably a little harder today but
it's a no this is the seat is a foot pad
like it's a it's a double layer toilet
there's like a seat on top you sit on
the top then you go like a lot yeah yeah
but the problem is when you're sitting
oh yeah yeah it's yeah convenient just
sit up there let out the one out of the
number one not the number two
oh
when you got to go number one you go on
top when you got to go one and two you
go in the bottom and then you're using
other people's number one
and if you're just a freak you go one
low below that
the upper decker
the bottom if you go if you're if you're
a real freak you go on the mechanics
trolley you're taking it into orbit ryan
how about we go to super chats
below that already
if you haven't already my friends smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel and uh share the show with your
friends we're gonna have a
raucous members only segment coming up
what do you what is this water oh you
want water over there in the fridge i
think you grab these those bad boys i
don't know if we had these upstairs
there was there was yeah these are we
have these um someone asked me what
these were actually this is a pneuma
clean hydration good i'm gonna get one
give me the chocolate one right you
really like those
there's no chocolate
no chocolate mint so this it's weird
chocolate mint sports drink this one's
lemonade it's uh it's like coconut water
lemon juice
himalayan pink salt stevia organic
cordyceps mushroom extract and
ashwagandha oh
luke is a huge fan of the africanus i
think ashwagandha is good it helps you
increase testosterone oh excellent wow
all right we're gonna have that
members-only segment coming up and uh we
will we will unleash uh these fellas
they just push just just there you
go times oh all right
all right let's read some of your guys
super chats while uh you know ryan goes
and uh uses the toilet correctly yeah
that's right talking about toilets
with the uh
yeah i'm scared so i just go pee on the
top one right he's like tim was serious
about his toilet right yeah i'll just do
that
all right let's read uh let's let's read
what we got what were people saying
cordyceps that's what it is right
cordyceps cordyceps
the type of mushroom
core
yeah
all right we got a whole bunch of people
saying happy birthday
frost says happy birthday tim i see the
old 690 brewer do a chocolate milk stout
those are always lovely you got to try
it buy yourself as many as you can with
this thank you very much we did
yeah old 690 we were drinking that's a
local brewery
for the state of the union drinking game
we did and they have they also have a
maple walnut stout wow is that i think
it was a house yeah i do like the stouts
it's like drinking pancakes yeah so
yeah for real like drinking pancakes and
they're good those are good i like those
too because you know uh that's better
than mint chocolate one well so what
happened was i got sick like i was like
feeling really messed up and i wasn't
getting better and my whoop was telling
me that i was sick and i didn't
understand what was going on
so it's like a healthy fitness tracker
okay so like so i was really i was like
yeah yeah yeah terrible so i was waking
up and it was like you're not recovered
and i was feeling really sick something
was wrong with me and i'm like this is
not a normal sickness turns out i was
dehydrated and what i didn't realize you
can't just drink water i was eating
normal food i was drinking water but
what happened is water doesn't have the
salts you need to retain fluids so i was
just drinking water and just getting rid
of it and so i got dehydrated and then i
had to get uh saline and they told me to
drink gatorade and so i did and i
instantly felt better and i was like wow
man i didn't realize i was dehydrated
because i was going to the bathroom
everything felt normal and uh you got to
take this stuff seriously so i went to
my doctor and he has a don't say
gatorade law that he just passed no
so we only drink powerade of mine
no sugar so no added sugar so it's got a
little bit of sugar and that's why i was
like all right i don't want to disagree
50 carbs per gatorade or whatever you
know i don't need that stuff sugar drink
sugar water all right let's read we got
we got uh happy birthday tim we got
happy effing birthday tim thank you very
much everybody's telling me it's my
birthday yes i am 36 i am i am old and i
am 36 and people are saying happy
birthday we got another super chat seth
is happy birthday happy happy birthday
anything on the crypto bill that biden
is signing it's a bill i thought he did
an executive order executive order
though yeah i don't i think it will only
help bitcoin
i think the government saying they want
a digital dollar is going to make
bitcoin strong it did apparently it went
down for a second but it's well when he
announced it yesterday it it dipped and
then it got leaked this morning and then
when the actual details came out
everywhere oh because people thought it
was going to be everybody thought i was
going to be i mean dude joe biden goes
hey i'm coming up with the crypto
executive order everybody's like oh this
is not gonna be good yup
so i bought a bunch of i bought a bunch
of bitcoin when they announced the swift
thing they were like russia's getting
booted i was like oh i better buy some
of this yeah and then it spiked and then
i bought some more again because i'm
just like yo i'm really worried about
what's going on with the world and the
economy and i'm pretty sure the world
economic forum types love cryptocurrency
and then it jumped again yeah i mean i
will say the one thing a real like
benefit of it is you know for all the
people who are like refugees or whatever
and you know you need to pack up all
your stuff and go to a different country
you can literally if you have bitcoin
like you can take all your money in your
brain
yeah if you know that like if you know
your seed phrase theoretically you know
where people in the past would have
taken their diamonds and sewn them into
their jacket or their gold or whatever
like you can just take all your money
and in your brain trying to grow bro do
you know about like um what is it called
when there's an escalation between the
police and the criminals
i don't know but
you start wearing bulletproof vests the
bad guys start using you know
armor-piercing bullets you start driving
trucks they start you know using things
that can like shut down trucks or get
inside of them you start storing your
crypto in your brain they start hacking
your brain oh yeah you're what is it
yuval harari that's the world economic
forum guy he's saying blatantly that
we're we're hacking breaks yeah i
watched it isn't that what the neural
net thing though give me your keys bro
you guys are gonna you got you guys are
gonna plug into neural links same as
everybody else dude being having a clear
brain is gonna be so what do you mean me
and him like will and you won't kind of
thing i probably will too oh
like people don't people don't realize i
thought you were saying like look at
youtube
[ __ ] well you're canadian so i
figured
[Laughter]
a lot of people are just plugging
immediately it's like
a lot of people are gonna say no for
sure a lot of people who are watching
probably will say no for sure
i think they've been 15 in 20 years it
depends on you know there are elements
where i'm like if i plugged in and all
of a sudden all my comedy documents are
kind of like right there and i could you
know i could see myself no that you
don't even mean that is they're saying
apple's gonna have a contact lens
that'll right that'll straight up it'll
be a contact lens and then it'll be like
augmented reality no but i won't like my
reports i'm not gonna i wouldn't enter
it for the coolness i would enter for if
i really i'm like this is gonna make my
life so much better how about this so if
they're going to be looking at my info
i would really have to be like all right
my life is going to be so much better
you guys you guys are missing one key
component
if so first non-stop i don't think yes i
don't think sure they're going to be
like forcefully putting chips in
people's brains it's going to start with
kids
young kids they're going to ask put kids
in your brain do you want and it's not
going to be a machine it's going to be a
port
so neural link or whatever they're not
going to come out and say we're
implanting a computer in your brain we
can access they're going to say it's a
port and you don't have to connect
anything to it you can choose what to
interface with if you want to
and what what will eventually get people
is if we get to the point where we can
simulate reality in your mind you know
everybody will do it yeah and then it'll
be like usb and cars would all be
obsolete and fine i don't know why you
don't have the right ports but that
doesn't interest me
what if you could click a button and
live 50 years in an hour but you are
committed to those 50 years of of
thought and it's actually
and then you wake up and it's back to 50
years ago but but in your room but that
for sure
it's like a prison set and something but
why would riley's brother
oh wow why would it be why would it be
mandatory so you got to look at how
things are implemented right when the
iphone came out it was revolutionary and
all of a sudden everybody was like i
want this thing it's got a camera on it
it's got a gps on it they know where
you're going and no one cared they
literally track you and spy on you they
can spawn differently
yo yo check it out uh it it is but
people won't think it's that they won't
think like they won't think they're
subtracting but they'll say well yeah
they have access to it but who's
actually looking at you you guys thought
you write down
how many
do you guys know what shadow profiles
are no facebook has a profile on people
who never signed up
so if uh you danny you sign up for
facebook messenger
it says hey can we help you find your
friends and you put yes it sends all of
your phone numbers to facebook along
with all of their names they see mom
five five five one two three four and
they say danny's mom is five five five
one two three four someone else signs up
and they put sister they put sister and
then it says john's sister is five of
five one two three four now they know
who your uncle is then you'll get
someone saying
they start connecting and then it'll say
janice co-worker and like now we know
her name's janice we know where she
works because and they connect they make
that profile and and your mom may have
never signed up people don't realize how
easy it is to capture all that
information so right now they know what
you're thinking even though you've never
interfaced your brain for real like
facebook knows when you have to poop i'm
not exaggerating i was reading a story
about how facebook actually figured it
out because they can track where you go
they know what time you eat because they
know where you're at they know what time
you get to work every day and the ai can
basically be like it is there's a 97
percent certainty that this person is
going to the bathroom an ad for the
squatty potty and they do
and then people so people are just like
how did i get an ad for this tv
it's not because they're listening to
what you're saying it's because they
know what you're thinking yeah they're
getting so good at predicting that's
like the camera channel
uh yeah there was that story about a guy
who started seeing mail come in for his
daughter about being pregnant and
maternity clothes so he complained i
think it was the target i'm not sure and
he was like why are you sending
maternity advertisements to my daughter
and they're like sir it's an automated
system if the system detected she was
pregnant they sent her the ads she
didn't even know she was pregnant she
was searching things like weight gain or
bloated or vomiting and the algorithm
understood those things meant pregnancy
and before she realized that they were
sending her ads for it so here's what
happened yeah there's a lot of stuff
kids are gonna get these and they're
gonna be like i don't understand what
the problem is and you're gonna be like
we'll be old guys and they're going to
be like don't you use neural link and
they're going to be walking around
seeing crazy stuff and then we're going
to get these like it's going to be
called like master link or whatever and
then we're going to be old people with
these weird bulky external things you
put on your neck and we're like i can't
figure out how to work the dang widget
and the your kid your grandkids getting
back let me help you grandpa why don't
you get a modern unit in your nose
and you're gonna back i don't know i
just like this one it works and the
buttons are bigger
i would imagine if you interact with
someone that has the neural net they're
going to be tracking year behavior four
four of the company and then like it'll
get to a point so like if you look in my
eyes and you're on the neural net the
neural net's gonna read my thoughts
cause you're looking in my eyes with
your net and then it'll be to the point
where like we have to do it for defense
you have to always be recording everyone
else's thoughts around you or the
person's vulnerable yeah then it's going
to be like everyone's thoughts are i'm
just i'm just measured
you people don't realize it but when you
get the option they're like how would
you like to be a level 90 wizard who can
throw fireballs from your hand
just plug in the neural link enter
skyrim seven and you are literally
feeling and experience the battle
against and there'll be so much to do
you know so many people for work it'll
just be like mandatory where you go you
know that the meetings are going to take
place in that and you go okay well
i don't want to work i mean that is like
five years away or less well but maybe
not
yeah because they'll say you can't
discriminate but the person with the net
is gonna be able to do five times the
workload well you won't even be able to
you won't even be able to enter the
online meeting board unless you get on
the internet they won't hire you they're
going to be like we do require neural
link is that okay and people are going
to be like yeah sure it's fine it'll be
there it'll be a discrimination thing a
supreme court case then
in 30 years when the first neural linked
person is on the supreme court is when
we're in
hell no it'll be a states thing where a
bunch of states are okay with it
republicans are like you can't force
people to neurolink you got to learn how
to clear your mind that's key meditation
because if they are measuring your
thoughts have no thought it's it's
that's the oldest yeah that's that's the
only
it comes full circle all right so you're
saying girls are safe
let's grab something
it's happy international women's day
let's grab some super chats all the
women we got christina h saying happy
birthday tim when are the rage on behalf
of the machine parody songs coming out
ps the website has also been a member
since pretty much the beginning highly
recommend to anyone that sees this thank
you very much uh i think maybe you guys
should do the gay parade
rage on behalf of the mission
i know did you guys see what ethan klein
was saying about me
so like yeah i've seen you guys biting a
bit yeah well i don't tweet at him i
don't care oh no i did a tweet ha ha in
response but i tweeted zelinski he did
the red salute and i don't want to do it
but he i was like i'm not sure if he's
supporting communism or black lives
matter and it's like very clearly joking
i think and and uh ethan klein was like
tim's trying to claim that like zolensky
is a communist for using the universal
sign of resistance and i'm like bro if
walmart is using that sign you're not
resisting anything like you're the
machine dude right you're not resistance
yeah it's so weird is that the universal
sign no it's not the red the red salute
is literally the communist salute yeah
it would be like if someone was like
well and i've heard the alt-right people
say this that you seem to protest and
they'll be like it's not a nazi salute
it's the roman salute and i'm like mean
same thing to everybody else yeah i mean
i mean
it's the guy out there being like no
this is the buddhist swastika it's like
sure but have that argument at every
party you have your own peril
all right let's read some more we got
rob maddie says i'd love to see you have
randall carlson on to discuss the great
floods in atlantis would be nice to get
away from the seriousness of the world
for a day pretty sure ian would have a
blast with him that would be really fun
for like a friday show where we usually
like chill and talk about crazy stuff
talk about the great flood it would be
good to i do want to refocus people to
really if we really want to come
together as a human race about real like
problems comet impacts you know they
wiped out the human race once before
almost so i don't want it to happen
again
andrew knapp says rule of acquisition
number one once you have their money
never give it back and that's the
ferengi does he work for blink
yes so blink fitness you guys may not
know this but they were actually founded
by ferengi are you familiar with the
frankie yeah in star trek they were a
capitalist star
trek right oh no i'm jewish it's fine
that's the deal the ferengi uh are
easily described as a nation that are
people that abide by caveat emptor buyer
let the buyer be aware and so they're
just they they they uh dude i love star
for the next generation let me
so you've got all these different alien
races that discover technology the
humans discover warp technology after
civil war and the vulcans come in the
ferengi bought it right that's cool they
made this this capitalist race and they
had a planet and when people when
traders came they were like we want warp
drive so they don't understand the
technology all that well they're an
underdeveloped society but they're
really good at mercantilism and stuff
like that right right right and they're
and they're and they basically steal
like sounds like my landlord do they
have
perception is that what it is really
good hearing or something and they can
like read their
levels i don't know about that but they
have big ears
and then like it's a thing in star trek
where if you rub their ears it's like
erotic or something oh my gosh oh yeah i
do remember that yeah
but the funny thing is it's sort of like
someone selling a uh the versace purses
they don't really know what's going on
with the versace but right they do know
what they the market values rub my ears
all right common sense says if the bio
labs are harmless simple labs focused on
food et cetera why would the u.s fear
them falling into russian hands unless
they were bioweapons that's exactly what
i was saying earlier because the
official statement from the us
government was we did help construct
labs uh bio biosafety level two in
ukraine but it's for food safety why
then
would uh well i suppose it's separate
then from what the ukraine is doing so
this is probably the the point the one
the labs the u.s constructed they're
saying our their bsl
ii
the labs the u.s are concerned about are
the bsl4s where the ukraine is working
on stuff but then i have questions about
you know people about this point do you
really think ukraine is is not getting
support from the us for bioweapons
research like if ukraine is building
these labs and engaging this stuff you
just got to be involved in some way
considering they're on the border of
russia yeah yeah maybe maybe not though
maybe not crang says boys boys boys boys
boys fellas
[Music]
it's about time we got a podcast just
for boys you know what i mean yeah i've
yeah i've been saying that forever
they've had all the murder podcasts for
girls now they're right boys isn't it
weird that women love
murder podcasts yeah it's a little
creepy why is that i don't know if you
know this but this is a tip for women's
day too that uh women are most likely to
be married uh murdered by their husbands
which is why you should never marry your
chick to keep her safe so
even if it's been 10 15 years and her
parents are pressuring you your parents
are impressing you i would never do that
to her and even if you do propose then
go to go to the store get milk never
come back life is important yeah the
more you know so the more you get
freedom over safety stay safe
yeah a lot of people saying happy
birthday so i really do appreciate it
happy birthday your freedom her safety
all right let's uh what do you got here
chris stark says if you go to the
partners page on the weforum.org you'll
find that all of the companies that pull
out of ukraine are with the world like a
world economic forum also is blackrock
and blackstone as well as cisco
very interesting creepy
the thong sound guy
yeah cisco that's right the thong song
guy you can't listen to thong song in
russia anymore
no cisco is like the biggest supplier of
food i think yeah oh not the cisco
system oh it might be cisco systems yeah
for sure oh yeah yeah yeah you're right
right it's the wrong i'm i'm thinking of
the food thing
you know what's crazy though is that
like when you go to a diner the food is
almost always identical because it's one
company that supplies them with all
their
you know all their ingredients really
yeah it's francisco it's the other cisco
is like sys or something yeah this one
is cisco cis oh yeah that's that's
interesting maybe the conspiracy is that
they're actually one company working
together on our food and security oh
all right adam says tim monero is the
future not bitcoin you said it was
tracked with the bitfinex hackers but
not true it was not necessarily to track
an error to catch them i would elaborate
but superchats are too short
the feds claim they were able to see
their monero accounts that's what they
did they knew where the money was going
maybe not true
maybe they lied
james cut birth says tim i had allergies
for most of my life until i started
eating uh until i started eating about
five years ago local raw honey it will
save your life jamie from hillsborough
oregon yeah i i did eat some local honey
it doesn't do anything like i get oh
i've done that too you know when i'm
same time every year i get as soon as
the trees just you know
and all the cars are covered it's like
flu symptoms but it's like it's it's
it's the same
i don't get any sicker or less sick it's
just like instantly i'm sick and then
eventually it just stops there's a day
every year where the trees like all the
pollen is just released i was up in
cyprus hill above the tree line and one
day my windows were open all this yellow
pollen came flying through covering all
my surfaces maybe that was today my
grandma my grandmother told me sorry she
had bad asthma and when she lived in i
think russia and she said there was a
month every year because it was before
like met allergy medications a month
every year she had to go to the black
sea because she's like i couldn't really
live where i lived national women's day
i have the same thing with you not i
don't get stuffed up i only get itchy
eyes that's it i had really my eyes were
itching like crazy last night yeah and
then today sleep it's like benadryl does
work though yeah wow i took some i took
some um i took a couple different
algebra
eat no bread it worked a little bit cut
the bread and sugar out try hydrating
the only thing that i found of
everything i've tried that worked is the
benedryl you know what you know what i
tried i tried eating papa john's and it
didn't work yeah i
had a bunch of pizzas for my birthday
and it didn't work
you ate all that bread didn't want to
bread it didn't stop your allergies yeah
for some reason i felt worse you know
his uh danny's eyes are always crying a
little bit
and i say it's because of inflation yeah
and i've been right this whole time
there you go you've been making that
joke for five years it's now yeah you're
right now it is chickens are coming home
the roost ryan
all right check this out paul wallace
says mit is now polymerizing the
material in two dimensions stronger than
steel and lightest plastic can be used
in everything super cheap to make
tell me about it maybe we'll make um
we'll make lighter than air vessels that
don't that are not powered so like ian
was mentioning like an
like a gigantic aero gel if you were
inside of it it'd be then it would be
but if it no no if it's really really
big it'll displace the air to the point
where the air pressure pushes it up yeah
so it can lift you if so look at like
big enough look at tankers right is that
possible look at look how big tankers
are how do they stay floating when
they're they weigh like hundreds or
thousands of tons what does take away
thousands of tons of thousands tens of
thousands yeah tens of thousands they're
cities man because they can't displace
the water it's like even though they're
massively heavy they're too they're too
uh they also have water in the
sealed in the hall i know that because
we watched one of those uh the netflix
with the the cocaine f1 guy or whatever
yeah you can use it as ballast yeah
he was an indycar driver who was also
this giant cocaine smuggler and he would
do it in that compartment it was full at
the bottom of the boat's floor so you
could have a vehicle that's heavier than
air but because it's so it's so it's
like not dense to a certain degree as
long as it's rigid enough and strong
enough for you to stand on
it would be so
wide that it wouldn't be able to push
enough air out of the way and the air
would lift it up it would float there's
a float to the top of the atmosphere
basically there's these hydro gels
they're working on all these cool
metamaterials where
they'll take like aerogel which is
lighter almost as light as air if not
lighter and then they'll take hammer and
they'll just smash it and machine it
it's super strong so i'd imagine you can
make chambers out of that and then
vacuum them out and create some sort of
buoyancy beautiful bacon says if there
is any sword that is destined to be used
to cut grass it is the master sword
yeah i was thinking about sharpening it
we got it from a mall we probably we
probably need to redo the hilt and
everything and like actually make it out
of wood or if we can stick it into a
stone and then like solidify it and
leave it someone can pull it yeah yeah
we need to put it in there
so the idea i had was use a magnet
and then make it so that if you know
where to push down it releases it so you
can pull it out in front of people and
then put it back in and release the
pedal and then they walk up and they
can't remove it okay it's like only you
only you are worthy
or like a hook or something in there
that hooks it something where it's just
like well then they would see the hole
and they'd be like oh there's a thing in
there but you do it you do a really
strong magnet you can't pull it out
that'd be fun
it would be fun and funny fun for kids
cia says honey is a natural antiseptic
happy birthday it is uh we also bought a
lot of honey and for some reason ian
bought a lot of vinegar
honey and vinegar i have no idea
dude when i was recovering from covet i
took a huge scoop of honey and i just
ate it and it was like the most magical
taste i've ever had of honey and then i
took another scoop and it was like nah
that's too much honey too much sugar
yeah yeah shocked
all right crimson seven says tim can't
buy a subscription for timcast.com
because i did that four months ago yeah
thank you very much happy birthday and
thank you guys for all that you do there
uh you know i'll mention too for anybody
having any issues just you know email
members at timkes.com we are absolutely
working our hardest to make sure
everyone's getting their issues resolved
we're trying to i don't want to say too
much for security reasons but we're
working on a resilience and security
program
and um we'll give a shout out to the
people that we're working with once we
have it all configured but basically the
goal is to be uncancelable and so this
means we're like building out systems
that might cause bugs sometimes but we
have to do it you have to do it
otherwise you know one day you wake up
and your banks close or something the
average weight of a of a cargo ship is
about 10 000 tons from world war ii yeah
how does that float well it's like
it's wide so it can't push enough water
out of the way so the water pushes it
back up and average weight of my ex-wife
oh wow exactly the same you have an
exercise
i i was i was getting uh i was just
trying to mix it up from my danny's
mom's jokes
it's getting late i wanted to give
people some of this street-ish all right
some of that good old-fashioned street
jokes dan c says tim if you're looking
for more swords check out
scallogrim people send him medieval
weapons to review on his channel all the
time and he's always trying to get rid
of all the swords he has oh interesting
that's cool yeah super cool we're going
to have like a cool sword room or
something
you know mary birthmiss says brownie
ninja thank you very much for the merry
birthmas
raymond g stanley jr says this is a live
stand stand-up comedy from boyzcast
thank you
that it is the boy's cast in the house
performer of the hit new single brian
stelter is a sex machine
he's a sexy man nate says bachbach
bakbak bark bakbak that is all if you go
to cast i'm sorry uh chicken city we
have chicken city live
and uh i will i will tell you this if
you go to chicken city on youtube and
subscribe periodically you'll hear me
screaming
24 hours a day well so uh 24 hours you
stream it 24 hours ago it's chicken city
bro
you're live 24 hours yeah really it's a
reality show man yo you're missing out
so there's check it out check it out how
many viewers does it have at any given
time it's got 14 right now i'm looking
at it
live pitch black
and we have over 4 000 subs
and today we hit like 120 or something
never doesn't stream well it's only gone
up a few days ago that's so check us out
check us out so roberto right he's the
rooster well he has a kid roberto junior
with the story
well yeah but check this out so roberto
jr sees dorothy and he's thinking to
himself like you know but that's roberto
that's one of roberto's harem right so
roberto jr runs over and chases dorothy
who's like no and
roberto junior won't take no for answers
so he jumps on top of her roberto
screams
and then roberto runs over roberto jr
runs away scared roberto then looks at
dorothy and jumps on her after him
because he's like you don't get i do
this roberto jr jump kicks roberto
knocking him off the head and then he
runs away dude if you have not watched
it it's getting wild dude game of
thrones it's like game of thrones you
don't want to have to go through you
gotta get the night vision so someone
goes we're working on the good parts
we just live stream it no but how do you
know that happened like did you catch
that people
posting and they were like dude look at
this clip and then there's other stuff
where like you can see one of the
chickens walk up to roberto and like
pack out his waddle because it's dirty
and like groom him and like clean him or
whatever so there's like there's some
emotion you know what i mean like you
get a lot going on over there yeah yeah
the drama the game even if a will they
won't they yeah exactly this is the
second time in two days that the power
must be flickering i think it doesn't
like you talking about the chickens yeah
yeah chicken city on youtube man so
we're working on the on the night vision
cameras we have them already i have in
new york i might do a rat city shout out
to everyone coming to the chicken city
live stream what's up everybody just
just film yeah just i just put a gopro
in the subway i just put out your window
they're like oh there goes one shout out
to terry oh in the chicken city live
stream chat what's up
the next season of chicken city we got
56 babies about to hatch right and so
what we'll try to do is we'll try to get
a live stream on the babies as they're
hatching for chicken city which is in
like a week just get a wild you know get
a wild animal put like a wolverine and
just have like massacre at chicken city
the animals won't come over here though
because so here's the thing i want to
mention
if if you're listening to chicken city
like at some point during the day where
i work there's a window and i can see
chicken city so i'll open the window and
just yell at the chickens because i know
people are listening in the stream
but then uh
yeah give it to her no i yelled uh
roberto
roberto
no i yelled roberto keep it down because
he kept yelling show her that roberto i
yelled hey roberto you're a chicken yeah
but here's a funny thing do you hear
roberto at six in the morning oh yes
yeah four thirds no no no no no no no no
he just never stops i hear robert
oh dude like it's getting we're gonna
have to like separate him or something
but i was yelling and dingo the dog was
outside
and he like watches me as i'm yelling
and then i close the window and i go
back to work and i have chicken city
open and then like a minute later he i
see him like you know i look out the
window and i see him and he goes
wrong
and i'm like that was the dog saying
what the f was that like opens the
window and just yells like what's going
on huh
but but he he pees on the chicken coop
which is really good it keeps all the
predators away that's good so the
chickens don't even realize how good
they have it man
they don't even know for all we know
we're in human city right now and people
are watching us
they almost they almost figured it out
the predators are trying to get in their
brains all right everybody here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna go film that
members only segment so head over to
timcast.com become a member and help
support our work in the meantime because
that's going to be live at 11 pm head
over to youtube.com uh well actually you
know the url is do we have one i just
searched chicken city on youtube and it
always comes up i believe it's uh
patreon.com slash the boys cat no no so
listen to a white immigrant go go
subscribe to chicken city and i'll tell
you this in all seriousness a lot of
people have been commenting that you'll
hear like rain and like birds and
chicken clucking and it's like nature
sounds a lot of people are like it's
super chill to like lay back and listen
to nature noises until 4 30 in the
morning hits yeah it's really plugging
the new chicken gym
you have no idea so we need 4 000 public
watch hours to monetize the channel so
you want it yeah yeah because once we
get super chats we can create this
machine that whenever we get a super
chat it throws like treats the chickens
or something so it'll like it'll it'll
like rotate and the treats will come
down and so people who are watching can
be like feeding the money
to the chickens and have the richest
chickens in the world and we're gonna
they have these 3d printed arms you put
around the chicken's neck and then it
gives the chickens little arms and they
run around and they're like this when
they run so we'll do that too all right
everybody you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
do uh the boys want to shout anything
out yeah the main thing is uh check out
my spatula that just came out a day i go
on my youtube channel youtube.com ryan
long comedy white immigrant is the
special just came out
yeah and uh follow me at danny jokes
everywhere and we have the boys cast and
then uh every tuesday night live at 9
30. i have a call in show low value mail
where is the call on youtube
low value mail yeah mail as an m-a-i-l
oh yeah yeah i'm ian crossland.net check
me out there and much loved all you
yokels in the chicken city live stream
i'm enjoying the uh the evening
thank you guys all for tuning in to
human city this evening i do really
recommend checking out chicken city i'm
really excited for the night vision
cameras i love listening to it you can
hear trains go by you can hear the
beautiful birds we have around here it's
a lot of fun it is actually a really
neat experience to watch enjoy you guys
may follow me on twitter and mines.com
at sourpatchlids and stay tuned for the
next one
people already i just checked before we
switched over and people already
tweeting at blink fitness oh really nice
i wanna i wanna give a shout out to the
next season of chicken city we have 56
babies about to hatch and we have two
babies set and raw you see set is a a
black chicken who was born at night and
as a boy and ra is a gold chicken who is
a girl and born in the morning and they
are the only two from the batch that
made it so i've just i just assume
they're the embodiment of night and day
yeah and they're going to team up to
defeat apep so of course yeah check out
that it's going to be amazing they're
going to have swords and whatever but
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out and don't forget
check out chicken city right now as a
birthday present become a member at tim
cast and subscribe and we'll see you all
in the member segment
you